[Music]
last night we
the even was geted up by baby he
said
even I speed hitting the gritty a grim
is shaking fornite
a GM shaking
fornite for
night yeah welcome guys yeah H Street
podcast it's Monday we are out here it
is uh November 20th which means
Thanksgiving every American's favorite
holiday I'm assuming or the biggest
drinking night of the year it is sure is
oh yeah um is this week night before
Thanksgiving right it's the biggest
drinking night of the year sure
is so this Thursday is Thanksgiving
we're taking Thursday and Friday off but
don't panic because what we're also
doing is
filming tomorrow which will be edited
and premiering
on Friday Friday our Friday episode is
our
annual traditional you laugh you lose
episode that everybody
loves so look forward to that so we have
a full week of show still uh even though
it's Thanksgiving and that's just what
we do for you guys wow now what do you
do for me yeah ask yourself here's an
idea of what you could do is um become a
member cuz we don't have sponsors
anymore go
that's segue I've never
seen a holiday season usually during the
holiday it's like three four every
episode like crazy everyone trying to
sell we got
NADA it's cancel culture
baby comes for all of us in the end I
mean I got the button and then
everyone left nothing I think it's I
think we're still experiencing the uh
the after effects of the pre-b button
days well
yeah obviously clearly nothing's
happened since we got the butt and we've
been great yeah but um hopefully next
year they
forget you know after the biggest
drinking n of the year yeah right black
out it is what it is it sure is but
anyway thank you to our members you guys
make the world go round in the a Street
podcast oh no un stamped hey don't stamp
me bro don't stamp me logo okay hey
don't thank you we don't need
[Music]
[Laughter]
thaty anyway thank you to our members
you guys make uh such a big difference
and I appreciate you all so much for
supporting us and keeping the show going
healthy and strong so thank you guys um
I just closed my
document
if you like a good-looking young men
with chestnut brown hair oh God what a
that is but that's me he's
talking about me
Chestnut yeah I have chestnut brown hair
a good-looking young man with chestnut
brown
hair's you have hazel eyes hazel eyes
and chestnut brown hair what does
chestnut brown hair even look like
you're not familiar with chestnuts after
everything you've been through with them
well I want to know what chestnut hair
like
it's such a like I don't know it's it's
an Amorous way to describe a young boy's
hair looks like hazel air in a way Hazel
hair yeah Hazel hair hazel eyes gorgeous
what's the avocado have to do with it
though what the Garnier why you put
an avocado in my hair didn't ask for
that all right where am I what am I
talking about t oh yeah so first of all
um Magic The Gatherings up online today
if anyone wants to go to Teddy br.com
and check it
out I'm wearing one
now sick
dude easy easy great ass you going to
get a strike um let's take a look here
Teddy fresh.com do you love Magic
Gathering Magic the Gathering I do too
we all do who doesn't who doesn't boom
boom the
jacket the cardigan boom boom boom now
let me hear you Sayo
wayo this is one Dan was wearing this is
one that love was wearing I was wearing
this one this one's so nice I'm I'm
wearing another one right which one you
got oh the classic dude I love this
collar it's my favorite col lavender
yeah Lavender is my though I love
it too hell yeah brother hell yeah I'm
big on Plum too I don't know if you
with Plum yeah I with Plum sure
absolutely Lavender is a great color
though um this is all really just a
beautiful magic
Art um that you'll find on a whole bunch
of beautiful pieces here I got that one
on then flannel you got this one on
right now mhm oh bro I like it P
Castle this one's crazy goes hard crazy
dude when have you ever seen that
before ever anywhere I love that one a
lightning zombie yeah dude and then
here's another plate one with a
beautiful
embroidery um so nice so cool
looking Ang you know if you're going to
an MTG tournament you better be rolling
up in
this yo oh yeah that's all I have to say
about it um there's so many great pieces
here the angel oh this one's crazy dude
whoa yo is that it's that send dib
eph that is I think it is I think that's
eph fre that is eph fre yeah or and a
fre free a
fre free the fre out of the bottle I
thought it was free I thought it was E I
thought it was e free E
fre that's
good check it out there's also Black
Friday oh wait is there still Black
Friday I don't see anything on sale
black wait what why did it say it say
Black Friday at the top yeah okay so
there's a different tab for Black Friday
check that out if you want to so thank
you thank you H besides that I was
so sick all weekend and I did not think
I was going to make it today but I had
to try my best because thank you Zach
there's so much good stuff I saw Colleen
is back and I says Monday
we
feast and I was going to be God damned
if I missed that you know after
everything we've been through the ups
and the Downs we've been with Cen the
power
points the P the power outs
[Music]
points indeed so this is I'm on an
exclusive diet of um yeah you haven't
explain sick how yeah so okay I at least
got some in good information when I talk
to you guys about it but I've had just
so horrible food poisoning it's just
up dude it first started on
um it started I think on um Saturday
evening and it started with these really
intense sulfur
burps have you ever had those oh yeah
they're the bro it is so
file and then not only that it was
sulfur burps like a you're like farting
on your mouth it's like it tastes like a
like a egg burp yeah it's like a egg
burp it so vile yeah that sounds and
then the other thing is like I'm not a
huge burper I don't burp a lot but
whatever's going on in my stomach I'm
producing tons of gas and I cannot stop
burping this active sulfur gu
you got fart mou you got fart
mouth bro that's crazy that's
crazy dude one of the worst things
it and then so and then the next day I
start having
uncontrollable chronic non-stop
diarrhea and it smells out of your mouth
and I'll tell
you it smells just like my
burps that's a
shame you don't I you don't want to ever
admit that but that is what it is it's I
didn't do anything it was the
you know I I I I take care of myself I
don't know ABY when do you get sulfur
burps I I was sick I don't remember when
but I've had them a few times when I was
sick recently God is it the worst yeah I
take Pepto for it helps so vile man I
thought you just meant like acidy burps
but you're talking about fart straight
up farting out of his mouth bro it's a
suuri
I'm glad I haven't had that dude it is
so up and
well then then the diarrhea started
happening and then I couldn't I didn't
eat anything yesterday I ate nothing and
it was just
nonstop and and and just to be even more
uh
specific
[Music]
um so you go to the toilet it's like at
a certain point you just give up on
wiping I'm sorry you heard me no you
don't hold up what was that not like all
the way but like there your whole ass is
like a canvas like it's like a jack poic
all the more reason a wipe I Haven I do
phen so you go straight to the shower or
what
usually usually I clean everything up
really good but after like the fourth
time in two hours the whole Jackson
poock things it's like you just do your
best you change your underwear you take
a shower you use the bed
cuz it must have been at least 10 times
yesterday and through the evening and
through the middle of the night
mhm
and you changed your underwear how come
I change my what you said you changed
your
underwear yeah dude not because I
my pants but because you pull it up and
there's probably there might be like
there's cross contamination sure okay I
get that I get that right so
so I've been going through a
lot and basically last night I started
taking these mhm Pepto bismal
poppers mhm I snorted a few of them
mhm I inserted a few of them right I
chewed a few of them it looks so illegal
with the black and white filter
on yeah I never seen drugs packed like
this though like street drugs have
you no seems too fancy yeah it's too
fancy it still looks like a PSA it's a
'90s PSA Vibe right
now um it's been Miser it's been
absolutely the worst and I told you guys
about it and I didn't realize but some
of y'all were also under the effect of
some really negative feelings and the
the theory is that it was from the
hamburgers is that right mhm I think so
I mean Friday we ordered me and Lena
ordered food after work and I thought it
was from that but I the place we ordered
after work I get all the time and I've
never gotten sick but this time my
stomach was killing me like I was in
excruciating pain so I think it's the
same thing that you have did anyone else
feel I felt slightly bad yeah I had a
tumm me a I had to cancel plans stay
home oh wow you did mhm I fell asleep
with a heating pad on my tummy oh my God
so who didn't eat the hamburgers Dan
yeah I didn't and you weren't sick nope
and Ela she ordered one but she didn't
eat it and she was fine and she was fine
cam you didn't get sick either right I
didn't eat at all well there you go was
fine good that's the way it should be
yeah yeah you see God rewarded you Cam y
yeah you guys been looking out for me
the whole time thingk yep trying to
protect you dude it's for own good Zach
did you Ian anyone else back there I was
fine you're fine yeah I was fine from it
yeah I was I was all good we must got
the weird batch well I don't know cuz I
had Mexican food on uh Friday
night and then I thought it was that too
AB but people in the chat asking was it
Anson stop they would never I would say
I ate a bunch of Anson and I didn't get
sick hold the phone hold the phone I did
eat a lot of
Anson right but we all did
however the chance that it was ion's
versus this disgusting nasty ass
burgers well the burgers were really
good the the after effects that I
experienced was worth it cuz the burger
was so good but obviously you guys had a
little bit worse than me I would never
eat another Hamburg again to avoid going
through what I just did yeah what you
went through is definitely worse than
what I went through show holy
the Gabe curse some are saying by
the way people got so upset okay I have
to say something I didn't even somehow
realize that Gabe apparently Gabe
invited us to his birthday party I did
not even realize that I was talking to
him and we invited him to the show and I
remember Mak some joke about how oh we
would never we would we would never
flake on you joking about last year mhm
I didn't even
know that we were invited to a party did
he say that I I miss that too I swear to
God I have I did not know until after I
just saw there was tons of people were
like super pissed I heard it and me and
my Dad tried to go but it turns out it
was at 11:00 well try okay well almost
only counts in horseshoes and grenades
bucko I bought whole outfit for last
year costume and I still got on
so yeah well you have the outfit so why
don't you go this year C Fu I didn't
know I was invited it's not the same
thing I didn't know was on what did he
say can we get a time stamp to the uh he
said where is we're have we're getting
together tomorrow night uh for my
birthday if anybody wants to come oh
wasn't he talking about his his nephew
was doing a concert Nick Nick was having
a show um and I know per cuz I talked to
Nick um I had no idea that there was a
party after up until this point I mean
that's a big difference he was like hey
you want to come watch my nephew play I
mean sure thanks for the invite but
that's not the same thing it's like hey
do you guys all want to come to my our
birthday and then we all just like oh
anyway that's I didn't hear that you
guys I would have made them
go well I asked about going but then I
found out the party didn't kick off
until almost midnight and I'm an old man
you go I mean we all have jobs and
I know Gabe is fifth in his I mean it
was on the weekend but
uh started isn't that odd to start
birthday partner at midnight no I mean
some of us were really excited to go and
we were going to bring we going to bring
my dad and stuff and it was his last
night so late I think because of Nick's
concert and they were like starting it
after it was like an after party to the
concert no I I I clearly wasn't going to
go and that's not because of Gabe thank
you Ian but like you expect you guys to
you know represent I was in Texas so
well there well done well done but
that's not what I mean is I mean is I
didn't I didn't even hear it so
apologies to Gabe we're gonna have to
throw a party just for him for all the
birthdays we've missed yeah yeah we got
to have a we got to do that I love that
idea we got to have a gab's birthday I
agree um Bonanza that's what I want to
do all right what else we got what else
were people angry at us for
[Laughter]
was there other stuff let's
see um there was the Gabe thing
angry I feel like there was something
else I don't remember oh yeah no I
couldn't remember yeah everyone was
super mad about
Whitney um for us plant forming a known
trans phobe that in their words you know
actually I will say this um about it
obviously Whitney is our like personal
friend
that doesn't justify anything but what
it does mean is
that you know you you sometimes endure
uh you endure
uh friendships where you don't have a
you know what I mean it's like I don't
agree with any of my friends on anything
there you go I mean Uncle your cousin
Tim is like I mean oh my God my cousin
Tim is trying to kill his brother right
now yeah he's L that's what I'm saying
literally I was like all right I got to
get off the phone he said all I'm saying
is I'm going full throttle and I'm going
to be his worst nightmare okay
God wait why is he what's the beef
between him and his bro oh God it's just
deep he he was living at Brendan's house
his brother then his brother kicked him
out and it goes deep I'm not going to
bore you so there's a whole Feud oh yeah
is it and do you think he like actually
if you're if his brother were to die
would he be the first suspect yeah 100%
oh my goodness but no I don't think
you'd kill him you don't think but there
is a chance yeah you never know you
never know
he's not trying to put that out yeah but
what I will say is that listen me
Whitney we're we we've actually have
thank you love I don't know what's the
color got like Mega stret it was on a
hanger I hate that happens yeah I noce
you got to fold these kinds of shirts
yeah you can't hang them or the neckline
gets all up
mhm thank you that's how I that's
yeah I'm showing too much chest though
right AB I think you look good thanks
bro yeah it looks fine I actually didn't
comment on the shirt it was where the
double just looked like Kenobi yeah yeah
um anyway so we you know we've been
through real friendship like when she
helped us rescue those dogs ela's been P
close personal friends for a while so
you know she reached out and says hey I
got this special you guys want to have
me on and I said well you know yeah of
course why not it's Whitney she's our
friend that being said I understand that
um she said some offensive things about
trans people and I I will also
acknowledge
that this is I think a safe space for a
lot of
LGBT q and even the
pluses feel in this community so there
so there is that which I think is
important to reckon with I will say
however I was was planning on talking to
her about some of the trans stuff but
um but um she left before I I guess we
just got kind of um sidetracked and then
she left early I I genuinely was I was
even telling you guys before the show
that I wanted to uh yeah you wanted to
engage with her on it I wanted to mix
her up a little bit but but I didn't get
the opportunity which is a shame cuz I
actually thought it would be an
interesting
conversation uh but anyway you know what
can I say she's my friend and uh she's
she's friend and and you know we we love
her as a friend um and but like
obviously I understand where you guys
are coming from too and I wish I had the
opportunity to um have that conversation
with her maybe next time um if we have
any fans by then they're not all gone so
that's what I have to say about that
anything
else um today is trans day of
remembrance happy trans day of
remembrance all I'll never forget
exactly I'll never forget my
trans
um brothers and sisters and nonbinaries
can I ask a question this might see dumb
and I don't mean it to be offensive I
just it occurred can you be non-binary
and
trans yes I think no seriously I'm just
laughing because the switch to D I
pressed the wrong button oh Dam like
it's a good question I feel like cuz if
you're transitioning to another gender I
was listening to um people discussing D
transitioning and how like people use
that as uh like a weapon against the
trans Community but a lot of people who
do treat d transition remain in the
trans community and they identify as
non-binary as opposed to like what they
were assigned as birth so yeah like
there's a lot of intersectionality
interesting yeah because okay it'd be
kind of confusing if they're like I'm
trans I'm trans nonbinary cuz I wouldn't
know what
to yeah you just say what are your
preferred pronouns then preferred
pronouns good question and you know I'm
a boomer I'm always trying to learn and
I love the gays I love the trans what
can I say I respect them and I love them
because prouns you know they're
they are the ones modern Olivia they're
the ones that get boot stomped by all
the scumbags in the world right now and
yeah that you know what I mean
nothing goddamn wrong thing with it um
it's
interesting as a trans person I love it
when y'all Bumble through trans
conversations yeah I'm glad that you
guys are are you know charitable enough
I I'm you guys see I'm trying my best
here you know what I mean I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to be mean or anything
I'm trying to understand my best friend
trans nonbinary okay okay there you
go so so if you're let's say if you're
born a man and then you go and then you
transition to a
woman do you like outwardly you
expressing yourself as a woman right but
if you go if you go from if you're born
a man and transition to
nonbinary I just what's so the
transition is that's you're how are you
outwardly expressing yourself I guess if
you're non-binary yeah well I mean or
are you asking specifically nonbinary
trans the combination people that
transition to I guess non-binary do
people transition to non-binary that's
what I'm asking that's what I'm think so
well you just identify as nonb just an
identity okay cuz that okay cuz that
person said their best friend trans is
trans and
non-binary um I mean I think it's just
going to be on a caseby Case basis
frankly we're going to figure it out one
by
one uh um let's do a pride minute for uh
gay uh trans Remembrance Day and frankly
we are here to
remember the trans
people why are we remembering them
because they matter and how dare
you even ask that ignorant
ignorant question today I feel
uh how do I feel today gay gay gay gay
say keep keep it going like a be
yes how do I feel
today how do I feel
today get the out of the
closet it's time to
transition
everybody search your
soul g
go g feel it g g
the
bigots the haters we are
remembering who we are and who we were
bored to
be whether it's trans gay
bisexual nonbinary all right it's been a
minute all right stop stop stop
disgrace man Jesus Christ dude let's
let's skip this part
today okay well let me just don't don't
take it off from me maybe just listen
okay I will say this Brothers I
listening G to this uh gay whatever
trans memory day and all that kind of
thing let me just say this there's one
person that always remember that person
is Jesus and he's seen you boy he knows
what you
done and you better get back in that
closet quick brother or else we going to
tell on
you
we going to tell on you Boy tell you
what the Angels threw her down and made
sure she was not coming
back that's the gels having their first
gay encounter the gels the gels the G
the gels the gels God bless the gels the
gels gels in the
Outfield Boots the ply
Gates I tell you what man I tell you you
don't wish I could suck on a nice fat
cop
without having God judge me boy I
jealous I'm jealous I'm mad you're going
to look so hot now get your ass to
church and beg for
forgiveness it was the worst pain I
think I have ever felt in my life I
wanted so bad to have a big old juicy
throbbing on each one of my goddamn
hands I can't wait to put it on you okay
and I wanted another one on my shoulder
and another one on my right shoulder
just I was I was crowned as the king of
I can't wait to have your in
my mouth Lord and that's my dream and
you don't think I could want to live
that dream but Jesus said ain't right
I'm going to give you the of
your
life whoa I don't remember that one
that's my gel
talking the gel s inside of me all right
thank you everybody happy
trans Remembrance
Day apologies to any of our uh many
trans and gay members who felt
uh unseen somebody's saying did you see
the Kid Rock protr article say what now
that was that the guy who was feeling
frisky yeah exactly I I'll look into
that who somebody was spamming that in
the chat so gay Rock gay Rock Grandpa is
feeling a little frisky today gr that's
what he says before uh that's what the
gel says before he slams you on the
ground oh yeah gases all right I'm going
to have another
Tums I still don't want to have a
diarrhea right now you
guys it's so not it right
now um what else was there happen over
the
weekend
I saw some people saying I haven't
talked about the Israel Palestine thing
in a while or Gaza whatever West Bank I
mean it's
Palestine um I saw some people
going I wish Ethan would call for a
ceasefire so I could watch the show
again this is Ethan
Klein maybe I should I'm not even mean
to do it as a
joke this is a serious message with
peace and love love to the Israeli
military I'm calling for a ceasefire
today now unconditionally to end the
violence do it to end the unnecessary
loss of life today is September 20th no
more violence after uh November 20th
please thank you thank you and no more
violence nothing no more bombs on a
serious note though of course some want
to see Spire um the amount of
just horrific loss of life you know the
majority of our children happening there
is just so so so
beyond it's just so beyond I don't even
know how to put it in the words it's
just hor it's horrible it's tragic it's
sad Israel is really up and
that's put it mildly I mean it's so so
so sad man the amount of of Civilian
death happening
there it's horrific the amount of
Destruction I don't even know what's
going to ever happen come after this
because the destruction and the death
that's happened there is just
unprecedented really in in the
conflict's
history and
um you know if the goal is
to have
net less terrorists your goal is to go
in there and come out with less
terrorism then this has got to be an
abject failure because I can't imagine
that
uh the people there who are having their
whole families killed and
Friends killed and homes destroyed whole
blocks destroyed and turned into Rubble
are going to be
um very eager to look for peaceful
Solutions for their out their out I mean
who wouldn't you know want revenge for
that who wouldn't you know what I mean
like being
real what is with the watermelon I see
people do that is that a Palestinian
thing what's with the watermelon I think
it is actually I think it's a
symbol I don't know wait what's the
connection uh I I don't know the history
how the watermelon became a symbol of
Palestinian
solidarity I will read about it right
now cuz I'm I'm not super familiar
either but I've definitely seen that
before in association with it what about
the hostages Leah says I mean oh go
ahead AB the fruit uh served as uh sorry
my mouth's full um if you cut open the
colors are the colors of a Palestinian
flag H the fruit
yeah that's what I'm seeing wait what oh
sure green red and black mhm oh okay
that's okay beautiful that's clever I
love I know in Israel a lot of the
watermelons grown there were grown by
the um
uh the Arabic or Palestinian population
did grow a lot of watermelons there for
whatever reason I don't know if it's
part of the culture or something but um
I do love watermelon so hell
yeah it honestly is god tier fruit or
whatever you want to call it a perfect
watermelon where it's like not mey it's
like a perfect crunchy it's like I mean
there one of the great joys of living
yeah no it's one of it's it's a reason
to go on it is true that's true it is
something to live for yep I mean golly G
will Ur to a perfect Watermelon
Man another reason I'm saying and this
was my guess as well but because of um
filters online to bypass filters of the
Palestinian flag they do watermelons
yeah interesting I'm seeing the
association goes back earlier than Tik
Tok though but that does make sense as
well emerged all the way back in the 60s
that's what I'm reading um so
anyway about the uh the hostages I
mean it seems from what I'm hearing on
the news is that there might be some
kind of
um relative closeness to negotiating
a ceasefire and release of the hostages
so let's hope for for that you know what
I mean I don't know I don't know what to
expect you know I have no
clue but
there'd be nothing wrong with doing like
a ceasefire where they try to work it
out at least you know you don't have to
keep bombing them every damn
second but with all that being said uh
thank you this is me Ethan Klein telling
BB Netanyahu if you are
watching
stop stop that you
you should go to
jail and I love watermelon and shame on
you you
I win baby killer freak
scumbag bring home the hostages yes we
need to bring home the hostages too of
course zero talk about the hostages what
what okay all right can't win this world
just just just stop we can't we can't
win we can work on getting the hostage I
don't understand how bomb carpet I
wouldn't say car I don't understand how
like Mass bombing of Gaza helps release
the hostages I don't understand that
that strategy from the
beginning I mean if anything it would I
would assume it would endanger the
hostages no I mean the H well the people
the most many I don't know if I say many
of the hostages families in israels are
the one leading the demand for the
ceasefire because
they uh understand that bombing Gaza
puts the hostages at risk not just for
being blown up by Israeli
um uh bombs but also being
executed by terrorists who are angry
that they're being
bombed thank you letting letting yaho
let let him naho go I don't know there's
something there let him let
[Music]
him uh but yeah anyway um we are going
to be doing eel pit at the end of the
episode
today
hostage have been blown up I don't I
don't know I I honestly I don't know
certainly wouldn't
be who's getting
cancelled eat
the it's time to get
[Music]
cancell
I didn't want people think I was being
silly oh okay yeah I'm being serious I
just said I want to seize fire and I
yelled now but I felt like I didn't want
people to think I was being silly I'm
being serious thank
you I am following the news very closely
I mean it's like the only thing I do
when I get home is just follow
the
news uh all right we got all kinds of
stuff to get to I don't know if I'm G to
be able how long I'm going be able to be
here
is it really that bad like well I don't
know if I if I generally if I have to go
to the bathroom it takes a while it
doesn't all happen quickly you feel it
cooking now though I mean it's always
right there if I went to pee I'd
probably shed my pants I know that
feeling yeah that sucks
yeah I usually always pee before the
show starts but I was like I can't yeah
well this Colleen thing is pretty long
maybe we should do something quickly
like um that eel pit story or something
well we'll do that at the end cuz I
wanted to get to them the okay the
headline stuff all right we have pokey
main so let's get to those two main ones
and then see what we have time
reevaluate so wow okay colen is back
baby wow this won't take that long by
the it's no but I'll take you through
everything we need to know okay so how
long has it been since she since the uke
song I've got days in that PowerPoint
all right well so we've we've um
prepared a PowerPoint here to welcome
Colleen back let's go ahead and open it
up and uh oh this is that is good stuff
she's back she's back girl you are so
back right now L really she's never been
more back do you think she's so back oh
my God your Photoshop skills are
incredible thank
you do you think
um a lot of her fans are going to stick
around she's back doing daily Vlogs
which is pretty wild I think that the
people who were like iffy on whether or
not they were going to continue watching
if they watch these Vlogs I assume
they're just going to keep watching
because like if you saw all of that and
you weren't convinced she's just putting
out the same like comfortable material
so she's just yeah she's trying to go
back uh before it all happened back to
the Vlogs
baby all right well
here let me put this on now I'm cold
I've been really cold too since I have
no um does poop keep you warm yeah for
sure what cuz my my poop whatz it's like
your like the more full of poop you are
the like oh interesting like a heating
bag breaking down all the I mean the the
breakdown would generate a lot of
thermal output right so if you haven't
been eating your stomach is empty your
intestines are empty I feel like
straight up last night I was like I feel
as if I'm preparing for a
colonoscopy matter you heard about that
uhuh you take you drink this like uh
some kind of fluid that induces the most
violent the fu grade
[Music]
system is that Eddie's
thing I did not feel
great certainly wasn't all right so
Colleen go ahead she's back all right
let's take a
look go ahead um Olive all right so just
so we're clear I'll
aboard Colleen this time
around was exposed June 4th that's when
Cody put out her video that's when Adam
put out his video and then Colleen's
ukulele video June
28th November 18th we're back baby
there's a really interesting
[Music]
um there's something interesting
happening in the framing of these videos
they all are speaking the same language
to me even atams right like they're in
front of a bed they're in front of a
couch Earth Tones their Center frame
Earth Tone what is the what is the
meaning behind this if you have a guess
even Adam well Adam is highly uh
influenced by calling yeah true right
that's what I the color scheme trickled
down but it's like I mean I maybe not
consciously but maybe subconsciously I
mean he was like a giant fan for years
right so it's not unreasonable for him
to take cues in the Aesthetics no
absolutely yeah his G his gray bedspread
does scream Coline you're right
alternatively maybe she stole it from
him I mean that is possible or well I
think was Trisha doing this before
anyone like on the floor crying oh Trish
Reed with the uh with the kitchen floor
yeah that's kitchen that's that's a
different different that's a whole
different B incredible you got to give
it up to uh Trisha for that being a
forbear did I ever say what her business
name was what I don't know what you're
talking about she her business name I
don't know if I I don't want to put that
out there if it's not public but it's
related to crying on the it's it's such
a funny name I I don't remember if I
said it on the show before if I asked I
don't remember either yeah it's so funny
here I'll type it to you guys and you
guys can laugh called okay I'm
excited this is the name of her business
that I pay to y'all are missing out on
some real funny stuff out in the
audience fomo we're making
fomo funny that is actually very funny
it's good it's good if anyone remembers
if I said it or not I'll I'm watching
the chat if they start saying it then
obviously we've talked about it before
but I don't want I don't want to put
that out there you know so it's been 145
days since the ukulele video that's a
that's that's a long time almost five
months huh and we'll talk about maybe
why okay let's go now
so just to get a taste of it she starts
this new Vlog um with an apology she
said it on the
show then then say what it is then
to yeah yeah I mean it's oh I'm I'm
seeing people yep they have it it's all
in chat yeah it's crying on the kitchen
floor
LLC the first time I ever had to send
her a
payment I saw that and I was like no
way dude that's that's really
funny anyway sorry go ahead Olivia so if
you want to click watch she begins this
Vlog absolutely with a very vague
apology hello everybody here she is on
the floor framed up beautiful bed by the
way love the bed frame agree nice
wooding there backing board very nice
beautiful backing what kind of wood you
think that is is that like a cedar or
um H let me do some
digging chest some digging oh no
definitely not Chestnut maybe mahogany
chestnut brown Mahogany's darker than
that oh you're right yeah I don't know
my wood true true you're not a wood you
don't know your wood I don't know my
wood what the why would you admit
that
what
uh I'm so
hungry don't do it I just have
pears and I have two hardboiled eggs
you're saying don't do it that's a good
amount of food
weren't you just complaining about Su
eating eggs those eggshell true why
should I eat eggs I was I was feeling I
wasn't sure about the eggs but I was
feeling good about the pears the eggs
yeah I guess eggs is a bad idea when you
have I haven't had the Su for burps
today by the way since I woke up this
morning they've been kind of cleared up
that's nice so supposed to be just in my
bum M nice par the last time it's almost
like I'm starving tastes so good the
last time you ate food when was
it last night this morning I had a tiny
a little bit of food oh you might get
the shits up for those
pears I did eat like I said before I
left something so and that didn't really
impact anything not yet okay that's
promising but I don't know if
like raw fiber is probably poop inducing
I don't know this is me that's you yeah
I love this
clip I eat pears now and like that
shout out to all the pear I eat pears
now and like that shout out to my
pear-shaped homies out there mhm you
know we with pears I had a really
pear-shaped body before all this so I I
represent the pears shout out to Bears
My Boy zy Rick R is gonna live
forever
app all right so Colin go ahead uh go
ahead by the way the like ratio is nuts
108 down 42 oh
whoa when you sent the link the other
day it was fine it was right at the
beginning that's why
oh okay damn I got that Bell
notification of course right yeah cuz
when you sent the link I guess right it
had only been posted a few hours before
it had a typical 90% like Ratio or
something but U yeah not a lot of views
I feel like this is a more
viral I'm surprised it hasn't cracked a
million but I guess a lot of people
probably don't want to give her the
views I wonder if there's re-uploads
with a shitload of views maybe or they
just watch like the reaction videos or
whatever anyway go ahead
Colleen everybody uh sorry I've been
gone for so long I've really missed this
I've missed talking to everyone every
single day um obviously the last video
that I posted on here um it's really
embarrassing to say the least
I was being accused of some pretty awful
things and I just was mad and um I
should have handled that situation with
maturity and empathy
but instead I just let my ego take over
and I'm really disappointed in myself
[Music]
um
so thoughts so
far well
she's first and
foremost denying the accusations clearly
by saying I was accused of horrible
things implying not
true uh but she is showing some
humility
the video is up it's still up I notic
embarrassed yeah how embarrassed are you
it's kind of a banger though I guess
girls got to weigh our options was it
monetized did we ever
determine um I don't recall I think
don't
recall but um but um bum anyway here it
is uh any there it is any day now and
and take it away
colen go ahead here's what I want to say
today
um over the last 15 years of my career
there have been moments where I was
immature and inappropriate with some of
my comedy and there were times when I
did not put enough thought into some of
my fan interactions and because of that
behavior people got
hurt she's trying to have her cake and
eat or to in a sense that she trying to
own up to what she did but also severely
downplaying it right
yeah I always think that when a YouTuber
is super vague with their apology it's
because they expect most people to not
understand the extent of like everything
they did so I assume like she has this
huge fan base if they weren't following
super closely and she's like this is
what I did I like made some in like in
po taste jokes blah blah blah and she
doesn't get into it it's like okay sure
I forgive you I'll keep watching mhm
right cuz I mean well the people that
are like fully appraised of the
situation are not going to they're not
going to forgive her I don't think
they're ever going to watch again right
probably not like like someone like you
for example and
so I guess in a sense in terms of her
just trying to make a living she's like
I'm going to go halfway try to get the
people who are kind of aware of it
back and I'm not try I'm not going to
try to even try to get the other people
back I'm just trying to think through
the strategy what's going on here yeah
yeah I me you acknowledge it but you
don't you don't go into any detail for
those that no detail yeah that's why I
got a perfect apology he one of the
things he said is you got to go into the
detail you can't just circumvent and be
like no I know what a perfect apology is
Lady you don't
right well maybe she'll see this and
take some advice they'll be they'll be
around three is my perfect apology in
this PowerPoint um I didn't include it
but we can pull it up you didn't include
it if you want to you didn't include it
uh it is perfect so I don't know it's
because I didn't want to I didn't want
to make Colleen feel bad obviously of
course for the old time sake yeah um
okay go on go on Queen also a lot of
people are saying she came back just in
time for the holiday
cpms which kind of funny true I have I
have stuff about that there's actually
yeah I don't want to spoil it there's a
more interesting Theory as to that oh
really oh just for the record this is
important to
say um Ballinger has not issued any
copyright infringement claims nor has
she monetized the
video so she's all good she's
absolved and I am so
sorry I never wanted to hurt anybody but
it's clear that I did and I feel so
terrible about that um I also feel like
there's probably people who are
disappointed or feel abandoned by me
because of my silence over the last few
months um and I'm so sorry about that as
well I needed to take time to
um
seriously what's happening what's
happening I clicked space and it okay
gotta did unintended thing right dude is
there people feeling abandoned by her
I'm sure her
fans yeah you got to probably factor in
and kind of related to what we were just
saying but like what percent of a giant
fan base is following every details and
like like what percent of the audience
doesn't even know that there was a
controversy you know what I mean or at
least just like only knows like the
Vegas like outline of it or whatever
especially her younger viewers right so
to them they don't really get why she
isn't posting and you know a lot of
people just don't they're not as
absorbed into YouTube culture and drama
they just they're casual that's true I
think yeah it's easy to lose sight of
that I mean again looking at Andrew
Callahan he's lost
almost not that many views really yeah
maybe 10% I don't know maybe I mean if
you're not super online probably don't
even
know and even the algorithm doesn't know
she's been like cancelled so she's going
to get pushed to more people after that
Viral apology video so people won't even
like know her right yeah I do I do think
though in like a month or maybe even
last a couple weeks it will it will
start to settle I think so too on the
real uh numbers yeah um just to take a
little tangent here I was really
surprised by the viewership that
um Channel 5 still has uh let's
see dude not only that he's crushing he
got the nek boys on 1.5 million views 1
million views crushing he is so
back quite the pivot yo wow that's crazy
his views are great
he's smart though he went straight
to nek to Vibe right now it's the gri
next he's going to be doing a video with
uh uh what who's the UFC guy Dana White
Dana White be jumping in Trump I smoke
marijuana so I don't beat my wife and
children did you see the golden shower
Trump video by the way I don't I'm a
germaphobe couldn't be real was so
funny not a bad defense to be honest
with you you know yeah know it made
sense even my wife says I wouldn't do it
I love that way he was like she didn't
believe that one that one she didn't
believe she let me off the like implying
that she believes most of
them all right Colin go ahead I was
listening and learning as much as
possible and um I also needed to um get
the help that I needed to to be okay um
I'm a Mom first and foremost before
anything else and um I needed to take
care of my kids so um that's where I've
been and um but I'm back and I'm here
now and um I am not a perfect person and
there are plenty of things in my past I
wish could go back and redo and um fix
change I don't have control over any of
that and I don't have control over the
things people say about me I only have
control over my actions moving forward
and so I'm going to do everything that I
can to make sure that I create a
positive kind inclusive safe space
online with my content and if you want
to be a part of my journey online I
would love to have you and if not I
completely understand um I do not expect
anyone to welcome me back with open arms
I don't expect to change anyone's mind
with this video I just wanted to come on
here and say that I'm sorry and um I
wanted to try to show people that it's
possible for someone to grow and learn
and be better after making mistakes many
many years ago um so that's what I'm
going to do um many many years ago
what's your analysis what she lied this
summer to people
about really horrible things that she
did it doesn't sound like it was years
ago like Trisha literally on her show
said that she asked Colleen did you send
my nudes to Miners And she said nope
they sent them to me so oh she blamed it
on the kids yes and that was not years
ago that's horrible and that's something
specific that like your victims would
like to hear an apology
for it's it's just
very it feels fake because she she's
apologizing in this video to who but
then there's like Adam and Becky and
Oliver and all of these people who say
they haven't gotten anything from her
she's apologizing to her fans she's not
apologizing to the victims that's what
it feels like because if she was she
would address it to them in a more
auspicious manner agree but um some
there what's that there a doorbell that
yeah why was there a
doorbell was
AB why you ringing it was nothing you're
good as she's doing what what she do who
it's like so loud ab's ringing doorbells
man we're doing a show dude the
doorbells I'll explain later okay okay
look forward to that yeah
um she also didn't manually leave these
group chats until after her ukulele
video or right before it was this summer
that she left them wait were they active
though um I don't know if she was active
in them um she was in them she could
have read them Becky talked about uh she
literally was in a group t with her
within the past year and a half two
years that's so crazy so God I'd love to
know what her husband thinks about all
this she hasn't I she posted a vlog
like an hour ago so I haven't seen that
one yet she now has three videos up um
but I haven't seen him in her videos yet
yeah he's I mean I don't blame for
wanting to lay low MH the one thing I
will say that I
have unreservedly feeling bad for is
just that because she's a mom yeah I
just you know it's just sucks
that I'm sure it made it really hard for
her to be present with her child and
sucks for the child you know mostly it
really sucks it's sad you know that part
is definitely true about when you're
going through all this it can
really affect your
presence of mine the two Vlogs I saw she
had she didn't exploit her children in
them which a new change we love that
yes we love that is anyone going to
watch though without her exploiting her
children isn't that why we watch we'll
see that's why we watch that's why
people watch it that's why a certain
group watches you're right we watch to
see uh children under the age of consent
being forced to entertain and not being
compensated or looked after this is why
we
watch this this this is why I'm
watching try to Vlog again and today I'm
just going to f my day and share some
simple happy moments and you know start
the process of starting over um and I
know it's going to be awkward and clunky
at first as I try to get back into the
swing of things but I'm going to try
so that's what I'm going to do and thank
thank you for listening and and thank
you to anyone who supported me in any
capacity over the last 15 years I really
really appreciated it um but yeah let's
get started with the day and see what
happens I guess I honestly do not know
how to transition from this conversation
into a vog people are saying the new one
has yeah I'm reading that right now
people are saying in her new Vlog it's
her children oh yeah they're in the
thumbnail oh no no no we're back here oh
man we're
back I will say
um
bold choice to combine the apology with
the
Vlog very strange bold Choice very
strange can
you why not why do that I'll tell you
exactly why D because you know those
views are slapping but is the
thought that people will see the video
because it's the apology video and then
just be so enamored by the Vlog half
that now they're going to subscribe and
start watching I think so so yeah watch
time is watch time I think she's right
if she was like here's my apology and
then in that apology she's like I'm
going to come tomorrow with a normal
Vlog people would not be watching that
Vlog agree we need clicks and she's
right but how did the day two Vlog go
that didn't contain an apology I guess
we're skipping ahead I'm I'm ruining the
PowerPoint right now no you're not I'll
I haven't looked at the views of it
recently I can look let's see I got it
so this so went from
then the next one has
260 and then the one from 1 hour ago has
20,000 but obviously that doesn't mean
anything well yeah the 800 to 200 is a
pretty big fallof but I mean if you're
posting a daily Vlog though and you're
getting quar million views on them
definitely a living that ain't bad well
what was she pulling before all this
something like 200k per it's going to
keep going down sure progressively yeah
it's going to keep going down yeah
and one of my actually I wanted to ask
you guys where do you think it's going
to settle at about you know cuz if it
was at 200 I could definitely see it
settling down to about a
100 may maybe less but I think it's
going to settle at 100 and then she's
going to realize that she can juice like
her own drama she's going to title it
like um I don't know and she's
going to finally apologizing right
something like that and she's going to
get 5 she tell the truth she going to
have these like just RAC this all the
time okay that's interesting
Theory um if you want to go to the next
well I want to see the transition here
yeah but um let's try where do I even
begin so much has happened since last
time I vlogged I mean if I'm being
completely honest the majority of the
last few months has just been spent in
therapy but other than that um the twins
just turned two which is wild Flynn's
going to be five soon um they had a
really fun Halloween
and we actually still have some
Halloween decorations up so I'll have to
show you some of those I usually have
already decorated for I watched a bit of
this Vlog it's really it's just her
moping around our house isn't it and
crafting kind of an interesting
job I thought vloggers had to do I
loved uh her like at home Vlogs during
Co oh really they were like yeah they
were just like this something about calm
Vlogs
is calm Vlogs yeah calm Vlog it's
appealing to some here she is uh she's
down at the creek we SP a lot of time at
the creek in the summer and we down at
the creek boy I tell you what man ain't
nothing like the creek get you going on
a
suay I see a shot of her husband but
every time I try to find
it I tell you what man I ain't never
seen a good bad Creek on a summer day
boy seen them tadp swimming up to the
top there now by
mhm all right so she's back yes so some
things Colleen avoided addressing the
names this is a a swoop tweets swoop
swoop Adam Becky Oliver Joshua Alex sof
Ella Bella April and the fans and so
many others and it's true she should
have she at least should have contacted
them
privately it's clear that
she I'm assuming but I do think it's
clear uh to me in my assumption right
that
she really despises these people yes she
seems very bitter toward she's not in
those head space of of Building Bridges
to them I think actually she could
probably
[Music]
um make quite a big bit of Headway I
think towards
[Music]
um doing the right thing if she did like
an
hourong conversational thing where she
really talked about everything that
happened in detail and offered uh
detailed and authentic apologies to
these people I think a lot of people
would be you know
really happy with the maturity uh and
and the approach I do think so I'm not
saying they should be forgiven but I do
think a lot of people would be
pleasantly surprised by that I think
we'd be much happier if she gave that
versus this video if we were met with
that right now instead of her being
vague I'm at the creek BR got them dang
Tad poles you on that hell you H tell
you what man I ain't seen no big tadpole
like that right into summer Dam where
she live what I talking about creeks she
Liv she in LA in California but she uh
she used to live in LA but she moved
more I don't think her family lives in
Santa Barbara but she didn't move all
the way to Santa Barbara I don't think
Santa Barbara ain't no Creek Country
that's so C anyway okay well said
swoopy all right possible reasons for
her quick return Colleen is being honest
she's taking the
time next there's not a lot of
supporting evidence for this one agree
but the happy face guys two thumbs up
he's stoked right because certainly if
one comes back this quickly they must
they must have taken a very sharp
180 okay so she's back she's learned and
then the other one is probably not she
probably didn't do that oh come on sad
angry happy face mhm so number
two oh before we say that I wanted to
make this point I made it earlier like
verbally but if it's still up how
embarrassed can you really
be that is kind of an
interesting I thought about that too I
mean if you have like this Mega viral
video if you remove it it's just going
to be re-uploaded by a thousand times by
other people so I don't know if she's
just kind of like whatever it's here but
it being on the channel I feel like is
her still like signing her name under it
yeah yeah I know I know it's hard to say
I don't know it it is a little
odd all right probably
not uh how embarrassed are you 16
million that was a juicy video
though dude you telling me you're just
going to unlist 16 mil hell
no possible reason number two the
monetization window of time is fleeting
it has been 145 days almost 5 months
since the ukulele video or it was the
day she posted her Vlog um and Adam
mentioned in his video and I double
checked and it's true YouTube will not
automatically remove your Channel's
access to monetization if it drops below
the threshold however YouTube does
reserve the right at its discretion to
remove monetization from channels if a
channel is inactive and not uploading or
posting Community posts for six months
or more
okay I seen this this um Theory floating
around as someone that's been on YouTube
for a very long
time and it's had a lot of different
channels who've been active and unactive
throughout the
years there's no shot that this is
really why in my opinion it's I I mean
I'm our main channel is still
monetized I get I still get paid for
that I've never heard of a
YouTuber's Channel just being
demonetized after six months for no
reason because they disappeared lots of
people don't even make videos that long
true or so there's there are creators
who make a couple videos a year you know
I have other theories I was surprised by
that Olivia was asking me and I was like
no that's that's not true but then I
looked it up and I saw that the policy
is there but yeah it's probably for
smaller channels not well they say we do
not automatically remove your Channel's
access to monetization however we do
reserve the right I mean they reserve
the right to do that to any
channel for any reason don't they right
yeah like yeah they're just trying I
think they're just trying to hedge
they're covering their
asses but that is in my opinion very
unlikely another possibility
she posted it the day of her
ex-husband's wife's birthday possibly
possibly a petty party one might think
are you on the slide a petty party yeah
I like happy birthday Pamela happy
birthday Pamela happy birthday love you
girl love love you girl love you girl
just a good day for you I hope I hope
that you didn't let it get to
you um so that's one possibility maybe
we wanted to be a little bit Petty but
this is the next slide I think I know
why we're back
uh Joshua said the only energy I want to
put online today is for my wife Pamela
happy birthday babe your heart is honest
loving and incredibly beautiful every
ounce of every day is better because
you're in it so this was
a okay does she hate Pamela do we have
any in swoops video she there was a
little section dedicated to how she kind
of made Pamela's life really difficult I
don't remember what did she do to Pam
she pam pam Pammy yeah let me we're
tight we're tight I call her p i get
this time stamp if you
want but okay I mean you know a mean
girl mean girl okay but I'll
get before the end of the show I'll get
X Y and Z finally my guess as to the
real reason she's back and some of the
ex fandom
agrees here it
is happy birthday
girl happy birthday cuz it was birthday
birthday it's tomorrow oh so she's back
for the accolades she's back for the
well wishes yes she loves our bday and
like Dan Dan your
thoughts I'm not surprised that she
loves her own birthday that's all say
Dan that our resident birthday hater has
chimed
in it's me
day yeah how often do you ever get to do
that once a year that's it that's all we
get that's important it's all we
get when's your birthday day I'm gonna
blow it up ju 2 never tell you
Cam what the hell man s me out I got
your
birthday what is the day cam July 24st
21st 24st yeah sorry I mumbl 24st I
mumbl yeah he was born 24st so you're
pretty close to M
D should we have a birthday party
together together you want to have a co-
birthday it's our day it's our day um
yeah I'm happy to share my birthday with
anybody well that'd be a little awkward
isn't Cam's birthday the same day as
year I don't like celebrating my
birthday we don't got to do that though
let's go you guys have the same
birthday we don't it's one day apart
okay that's not the same it's one day
yeah so we should just celebrate Ethan
and
dance and cams no well are you oh let me
ask you this are you before or after
Dan's birthday before so we don't got to
too far away yeah it's too far
so we're just going to combine Ethan and
Dan this year can we combine them all
just everybody in the office that' be
ideal that'd be sick I want my own day I
don't know what you guys are talking
about let's just do a big Bonanza for
all of us Olivia's not long after us I
invite Gabe yeah we can invite Gabe yes
Gabe's birthday featuring everybody else
all right happy birthday Colleen we love
you girl how old is she love you girl
3 6 so I think she'll be 3 7 37 girl
she's a baby she's a
baby so it's tomorrow this is just some
of the content of her birthday through
the years the girl loves her birthday I
get it B news I'm one year older than
this wait hold on how can that be I was
born in
1985 uhu and I'm 37 it adds up
exactly am I 37 or
no see now you're 38 you're 38 my
brother so that's what
okay well you're 42 for being real so
then why is it she's two years younger
than me well her birthday is tomorrow
okay that makes sense yeah old
ass old ass
dummy weirdo
weirdo mine's slipping slipping with
that age time to get that Life Alert I'm
about this I'm going to gift her ass a
Life Alert old ass let me have change
your mind all right so here we she she
has a uh she's in a birthday enjoyer
unedited footage of us singing at my
birthday oh brother my brother my
husband made me cry on my birthday
calling Baler birthday vacation a good
title right there she is
very birthday girl coded she's very
celebratory of her
own wait hold the phone these
are all from the
same three of these are from the same
year yeah she she does birthdays and she
also does her uh yeah yeah she does a
fundraiser on her birthday I don't know
if she's doing it this year that's nice
we like fundraisers yeah what is she
raised for Childhood Cancer g h damn it
it's hard to top that one yeah can't
really say anything bad about that
seriously listen if my can I make this I
have a funny joke there's rumor the
Colleen I'll make a joke Dan and then
you you button it if it's not good I was
going to say if my kid was see I don't
even like the that premise yeah I was
going to say if my and this is not me
talking about my kids this is a
hypothetical if my kid was dying of
cancer I would say no to her money what
the not that funny not offensive
but not funny it's less offensive but
it's just I just I thought it was a
funny idea of someone hating her so much
yeah right that they refuse the charity
money no it's beautiful and all kids
with cancer need to be treated all of
them right Olivia right right so these
three videos were from the same birthday
year 2022 last year Cullen's birthday
and our first time at her new house what
do you mean at her new house what about
our house is say your family's house
that's probably the Ballinger family's
video oh oh you're right it's always a
Colleen birthday
Extravaganza okay so there's unedited
why do I need need unedited footage it's
a vlog I want it
edited it's bonus what is this JFK
who assassinated JFK edit that
and they used to go to Hawaii for
her birthday every
year I mean oh yeah not a bad idea okay
so she loves birthdays she's back just
in time so what have we been up to she
discovered rocks no she's been watching
our show bro she discovered rocks
that she's got it in the water no no no
I put a clip of us okay that's us that
would be crazy she turned into a crystal
mommy she turned into a rock
Mommy I gotta watch I got to see what
she's saying about rocks I'm somewhat of
an expert myself
now and then I got really into rocks in
the last couple of months which I know
I'm literally rocks like not like
diamonds like literal rocks like trash
rocks that you would walk on and not
even think twice about like call Rocks
trash take that back what scum
the did you just say why would you
call your own hobby trash shame on
you I mean once you cut them open
they're trash then you throw then you
throw them in the dumpster but when
they're unopen they're they're little
their Little Treasures right maybe I'll
talk about that another day because
that's intense Flynn started soccer
which was really exciting he started a
school the kids have all changed so much
I don't even know where to start or what
to say they're just like the most
incredible little wonderful perfect
hilarious magical humans I feel like
every single day there's something Ro
she's still talking about rock I was
literally just typing you can keep
watching if you want to but that's
that's it for that I was like oh magical
little
humans wait I want to hear that again in
the last couple of months which I know
I'm literally rocks like not like
diamonds like literal rocks like trash
rocks that you would walk on and not
even think twice about like I have
become obsessed with rocks uh maybe I'll
talk tell me more well how you going to
end it
there her Vlog the next day there's more
shows some more rocks if you're
interested but then she goes yeah I am
what did you say about magical little
humans about that another day because
that's intense Flynn started soccer
which was really exciting he started a
school the kids have all changed so much
I don't even know where to start or even
what to say they're just like the most
incredible little wonderful perfect
hilarious magical humans I feel like
every single day there's something
that's how real Brock enthusi feel about
their Rock so not sure I'm taking your
hobby too seriously chestnut brown here
he's a
poser all right so I want to see wait
okay where do I see more rock
info need more what's this clip from
I'll grab you the rock content I want to
judge her
authentic uh Rock eny facing on that
that Crystal up there you see that I
believe that's a jade Yoni egg
here you are oh I got two this is the
ginger one oh thank you you're welome
nice hey girl people are asking for a
closer look at that mug that Halo
mug why do we have a Halo mug it's mine
you brought this from home mhm is it
okay I'm using it yeah it's fine it's
for everybody unless are you going to
fart in it with your fart mouth
dude no I
hav well I don't know D is your
dishwasher going to wipe off my fart
breath Halo I don't I don't have
fart breath anymore okay if I did i'
blow it right in your face all right you
go ahead and you go no but it actually
smells so V that I would have these and
I I'm not a burper but I have these
monster burps I'd have to
go throw it
away you know what I'm saying AB yeah
it's it's the worst I can't I'm
surprised not everyone has had them I I
only had them the for the first time
like maybe two years ago oh really and
it it was just can we do a poll for
who's had fart burps how does that even
work dude um it's just some kind of
bacteria in your gut starts producing
sulfur literally I figured the fart
backtracked no no no
no a lot of people know them as that's
definitely not what's happening Jesus
made made sense to me at the
time those egg shs I think that can
happen if you get like Mega constipated
yeah but it's not it's stomach
I'm glad glad for you it's not in
my mouth so it could be worse it could I
guess yeah I could
sure I could literally have in my
mouth that could be
worse yo a full like 30% of our audience
has got those mouth farts dude I
so I'm so happy and relieved for the 70%
of you guys that have never had to deal
with that and I hope that your life
continues on that
trory and you can live happily without
farts in your
[Music]
mouth fart burps are real literally
Google
it it's yeah suur burps Google that
still real to be Dam smells like rotten
eggs stop saying that I'm going to vomit
literally thinking about
it I'm I'm I'm amazed I didn't puke dude
I
was sounds nasty I don't think I I don't
think Eli should ever kiss me
again you're ruined you're sullied
forever you remember in The Matrix when
agent Smith like clayed his mouth shut
yeah that's what needs you're hoping for
that all right did I get some Crystal
mommy
action yeah I sent you a time stamp
thank
you yes girl what I've been up to
yes show
me that was a okay that wasn't a stone
that was a sand
[Music]
dollar so is she going to cut these open
or yeah where's the Saw we just look at
is there Jade in them that a shell those
are all shells that's what I'm saying
that's a sh oh my God she's calling
rocks trash she's picking up shells
glass that's glass
that's all glass SE glass people collect
that's human made garbage it's not
Mother Earth's beautiful treasure
uh-uh all right this is pretty dull col
this sucks this this Vlog is pretty dull
that's a horrible rock
collection you don't know how to do
rocks I bet that's not even worth like
five bucks oh is she going to polish it
wa turn it up I have two different
tumblers I'm opening today this one I I
think these were rocks in stage two
there's four
St most of these
been this one is stage one the ones in
here
are and the ones in here are mostly
courts like Jasper I don't even really
remember honestly but I think it's
mostly probably Jasper quartz nagot
let's open them
up as if anyone cares she said you don't
here we go going to open this
up the great stuff not delicious like it
says in the Beauty and the Beast song
great step is grit all right this Ginger
to Sweet scrub them with the toothbrush
did you put something in it or is it
just sweet yeah that's just the flavor I
didn't add anything
interesting and then we put them in the
next
cycle oh my gosh they got so small I am
shocked I can't believe how much they
broke down that's crazy how fast that
happen I I'm
done this is a rock vlog
rocks I went to T really excited them
this is a show you very exciting but I
promise they will Vols against it and
most do you think she'll ever get like a
real job acting again seemed like it was
all happening for for a minute didn't it
um she was doing play she had a show in
terms of roles that she played in
mainstream it was I think just Miranda
and then she was Dawn in Broadway that's
good which is amazing incredible I just
don't know if anyone going to cast
Miranda anymore like I I think that's
totally doneand no no no no no Miranda's
never coming back she should have just
blamed it all Miranda that's what I said
listen this Miranda character she took
over she's crazy that she is
crazy all right we love rocks yeah and
we love love this is this yeah this this
is a lot showing off her bony little
back so um some people
okay so that was a line in the song yeah
in her group chats with miners she was
known to say you look so good you look
skinny to her like kids that she would
talk to and she told Adam like you look
great you look thin um and in her song
she turned her back around after people
had criticized her for body checking and
fat phobia and she said look at my bony
little back and so some people are like
is this just a like is this a body check
what's why the first one back Dan trying
to save you with that what are you
talking about no you're right but I'm
saying I'm glad that Dan I to pull I had
to yeah yeah yeah I had to pull the the
evidence yeah well there was a lot of
conversing at the time about
her having some kind of weight issue
where and I learned what this expression
is body checking when you go sideways to
show MH it's like a pro I don't know
correct me if I'm wrong Pro anorexia or
like glamorizing it's eating disorder
yeah yeah yeah that's what body checking
it's you can body check by yourself it's
just she does it in her Vlogs so people
watch it because in the song she says my
bony little back yeah and
presumably during this time she's also
been
um not eating great probably she's been
under a lot of stress a lot of anxiety
I'm assuming I hope yeah physically
she's okay and does like showing that
off is kind of concerning right because
that's not
again I don't love talking about
people's bodies but um I mean there is
something going on here right she liked
talking about kids bodies so I don't
know fair
enough can you look at this and say that
she's like she's always underweight or
she's always been little um I I do I do
hope she's okay but why show it off like
that yeah I don't know in front of the
Paw Patrol toothbrush first selfie back
is the only the first selfie back why
would you do that in front of rubble
like Paw Patrol he's too sweet to see
all this cover his
eyes
serious okay yeah some thoughts from the
victims I timestamped Adam went um I
like he was gone just in Timberlake 9s
Vibes yes Ramen we love the ramen boy
serve me that
Ramen and the video with saying that
he's all tatted up what happened did he
always have tats he's been growing the
tats look at him you've changed dude you
got tats you got that Ramen hair so do
you you got kind of a mullet going on he
looks edgy and cool dangerous show him
your T he looks dangerous I have a tat
yeah tap boys twinsies tap boys I love
Shredder I miss
him oh yeah and here you go you did
first
dude right now haircut you even got the
bullet well yeah and I'm also edgy and
dangerous in a bad boy yeah with tattoos
with tto I'm tatted up badass I'm tatted
the up that's not Rubble how would
you know that is Rubble that's Rubble
that was the Bulldog the bulldog's name
is Rubble stop name of Paw Patrol I'm
lost Bulldog somebody said that's not
Rubble it's Rubble you coward
you
liar how dare you question my Paw Patrol
knowledge called out dude yeah I'm sick
of these Chatters yeah them so hold
on he's on the PAW Patrol but he's a
construction worker well the PAW Patrol
they all they're all different like
they're villag men kind of like one's a
cop one's a firefighter one's
construction and one has a helicopter is
there a Native American no Dan that's
racist it's not it's cuz there's one in
the Village People what's their machine
going to be um I was making a joke about
the you made you made the connection to
Village he's the most iconic Village
person he the Native American by the way
the Tepe thing was Dan's racial uh I
didn't
say I said what's the what's the PAW
Patrol American do fly around in a
teepee yeah you said that no you said
that is there an Arab there there an
Arab the Arab one yeah what is their
special ability AB
um
nothing just a dog what kind of dog
would it
be uh I don't know you haven't thought
this through have
you but anyway that's Rubble let me go
back and just make sure if I don't want
to go off the hinges on this
chatter um yeah let's double check that
dude that's Rubble you liar you
coward on the toothbr you
fool I see yeah I got kids don't
question my you fools all right
where are we um yeah click the right the
video I got sidetracked that's Sor oh
here we go we and the video saying that
this is the woman who that's
Rubble that's Rubble that's
heli that's that's
Marshall and that's um Chase Chase thank
you chase is on the case baby yeah Chase
is the cop that's the cop he's a
aab I don't like Chase yeah Chase I
don't like
chase you know what I mean defund the
let's just let's zoom in a
little bit more and there we go that's
much better Rubble is definitely the
coolest cuz or I mean Marshall's cool
too cuz it's like he's a Everyone likes
firefighter oh firefighter role yeah
yeah but all they're all cool wa what uh
what is uh she's a helicopter she's a
helicopter she drives a helicopter she
is a helicopter she flies like the the
rescue helicopter whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah which is cool Someone Saved Me
ban the rubble denier people are
saying I'm going to find out who you are
I'm going to find you all right anyway
go ahead
Adam exploited me and so many others
this is the woman
who we sent back and forth Trisha Pet's
nuds for her name is Sky what did I say
her name was which I almost commented
that that's strange name that's a
different yeah Sky sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry Sky drives the you are so
over put a lot into question about what
you've been is a different show it's a
different show sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry from whenever I was like 15 this
is the woman that told me about her sex
life when she when I was like 15 14 so
when you see this innocent woman just
know that that's what it is and I'm not
here to to cry I'm not here to get angry
anymore I'm just fed up and listen
that's the information you've all seen
it on the internet this is the woman who
told me about her sex life this is the
woman who asked me about my dating and
sex life this is the woman who was
asking me if I'm a virgin what my
favorite sexual positions are this is
the woman who other members of the
weenies have came forward saying that
she was always inappropriate me with me
whenever I was a child and she was also
inappropriate with them when they were a
child this is the woman who literally
trauma dumped on me so daily that I
can't even kind it this is the woman who
would get me ask me to hide things from
my parents this is the woman that would
tell me secrets with the benefit of me
getting something in the end would
dangle little treats over my head so
that I would do whatever she wanted this
is the woman that tried to get so deep
deeply involved with my life and tried
so desperately not to get my parents
involved this is the woman who anytime I
would meet up with her wouldn't want my
parents to be there you've all seen the
text messages when we were in Dublin and
she freaked out at the thought of my
parents joining us and then abandoned me
in Dublin whenever I was 15 years old I
didn't see that oh do you want to know
that story yeah um when she was in town
performing it was I think like the day
she announced that she was dating
um she invited Adam to meet them for
lunch and Adam's mom drove him all the
way it was like a 2-hour drive and um
she was texting him the whole time like
come on Adam like we're we're we're
almost done blah blah blah he's like I'm
coming I'm coming and so finally when he
showed up they had already gotten him
food they had eaten so he sat down with
them for like 20 minutes and then she
was like we're going to go back to the
hotel you can walk with us and then she
just left him in Dublin alone
his mom left him there well luckily his
mom picked him up but Colleen left him
there that's pretty
gnarly what a Jesus Christ how old was
he at the time like 13 or something yeah
probably like 14 15
Jesus can you just hang out for a little
bit I mean damn exactly Pages what they
order him a hamburger they did they did
I
remember a hamburger talked about it did
he or ask for a hamburger or did they
assume he wanted a hamburger that I
don't
remember that would tell that would say
a lot that would say a
up this is the woman that has done
that there's so much to say whenever it
comes what who are these people in chat
saying he's faking his accent he's
literally wait he's secretly not Irish
is that the the he's Irish you
weirdos someone says he's Scottish I
don't know he's from I don't know he's
not this is how he's always sound he's
Scottish not really Irish he the man
sounds like this what that's such a
weird what are you
doing Binger and her ability
to completely evade who she actually
is this is the woman who is sitting here
saying if you're going to be a part of
my journey this is the same woman that
bullied her fans with me
like this character that she's created I
witnessed it in the moment but I was so
close to her that I didn't care I'm out
of that Nigh I'm an adult nigh and if I
can tell anyone anything be careful on
who you support if you want to be a part
of this vlogging Journey that she's a
part of go for it do it it it listen you
could it's your prerogative you can
watch and support who you want to watch
and support but all I can say is tread
lightly when it comes to Colleen Binger
yeah I think we've all learned that but
thank you Adam and uh you know
what speak your speak your mind boy yeah
say what's out there in your heart and
then oh so sorry and
then serve me up some of that Ramen
because I'm looking for a hot meal let's
go does that I didn't mean that in a
weird way is if you like a goodlooking
young sound I didn't mean that in like a
sexual way I don't know if it came off
like that no no no Adam your hair looks
bomb yeah I like it um and then I
included thoughts from the other victims
I just put tweets from Oliver Becky's
tweets Ella's tweets sof tweets if you
wanted to read them the top comment
is pinned by Adam I don't know how to
transition from this conversation to the
Vlog part yeah because you probably
shouldn't have put it all in one video I
mean right that's why that you know
that's
it Colleen has personified the meme of
yeah I hurt you but now you hate me so
I'm the real victim here
interesting it was interesting uh
psychology um shout out to
Adam we love the look this is Aller so
Oliver was
the guy yeah he um he was would speak
with Trent Ballinger right right right
right okay yeah Oliver Who We Love
Oliver
said what I let me read this in the yeah
what the so I wonder if she knew
she was posting that on her
birthday what are the chance that she
knew that she knew you think she knows
her his wife's birthday do you if it's
that close to her birthday she knows it
right that could explain why mhm so how
many days why would that factor into it
though like yeah you're like oh my ex's
uh my ex's ex has like almost the same
birthday as me no I'm not saying why
would she remember the ex's birthday why
would that factor into her strategy of
one to post it Petty but what it's a
petty party yeah it's a petty party but
it what like I tend to agree with you
more Dan why would she talk to minor you
know like why does she do anything well
I
mean why does anybody do anything
but I the the the ex-husband and and and
in particular the ex-wife didn't have
anything to do with this situation the
present situation she's certainly
spiteful about Josh right now CU he sat
down and did that interview oh because
of the interview thing yeah okay I mean
well let me ask you this do you think
that Josh or his current wife cares that
she posted the video then I don't think
they would care at all they're probably
annoyed you think so yeah well he did
post about it like remember he he said
the only energy I want to put online
today oh that was his response yeah he
was like I'm just celebrating my wife
today got
it he kind of made it that okay I mean
he put it out there more that like oh
she's posting about my wife's birthday
maybe it's kind of crazy that it was a
same day I maybe I'm just not I'm not
brain poison in the same way that I
don't understand like the strategy there
but I I believe you you know more you
you know the most about the civia he's
the expert yeah it's really just at this
point like any mean thing I'm like I
can't I can't write it off people are
saying she wanted Josh's attention on
Josh's wife's
birthday it's narcissistic behavior well
he did give her attention he did
basically address her in his tweet
that's true I clearly he was thinking
about it he was talking about it yeah so
that that did happen true although I
don't think Josh has has any feelings
for Colleen does he no but he's
certainly hurt yeah he's hurt which I
guess means something
yeah Aller continues excuse
me Colleen says nothing about Trent
throughout all of this really makes me
think that she doesn't want to condemn
his action that's a good point by Oliver
totally Oliver of all the people
involved in this was in my opinion the
most and okay I shouldn't I'm not trying
to phrase it in a way that makes anyone
else's more so or less so but on a
personal level I found their interaction
super disturbing Oliver was very much
prayed upon oh my God that was just
straight up pedophilic
grooming like in the truest sense of the
word not in like oh what does grooming
mean no like that's what it is what's
your you're not even apologizing or
addressing that she fostered a
relationship with her fans that allowed
for her brother to get close to them if
she's not going to say that and she's
going to put her babies all over YouTube
girl yeah you should say
something that
was that brother is wild yeah
what's your
argument shut up Dennis I'm not talking
about freaking incest we're not even
talking about incest yeah brother and
sister want to make love all right bro
SS somebody escort him out get him out
of here
AB we need what we need is more Prager
you videos stat
incest Oliver continues excuse me I'm
got lots of gas now uh oh oh no oh no
wasn't it wasn't a sulfur one nasty bro
this sound like windy it wasn't a sulfur
one it was tasted like ginger oh that's
nice I think the ginger is helping
that's good I haven't been able toink
drink a lot of liquid and I'm so
tired Dan I okay I'm sorry for giving
you a hard time on proceed please I
hungry too did I mention that I tell are
you cold I could
tell I'm okay I'm cold you are nice job
with the air conditioning you want to
turn the AC down I mean you you you
asked it to be on my top is hot my
bottom is full see right what do you
feel about that maybe like down one
degree it's cold as the thing is the
thing with the AC it is so I must be I
wasn't saying anything yeah but you
don't feel well so I feel like I put a
hoodie on I feel better now with a
hoodie on I'm also under the vent here
so I'm definitely feeling it so hold on
let me take this off then and then you
can turn the AC off that's a compromise
jack it off let's see if that works I
got I got the fan on me over here really
yeah same okay Midwest Bo all you guys
are one this gu from Sweden he's he's
cold dude the AC the AC cool is
something I'm not used to I'm I'm used
to the dry the natural Co yeah the thing
is um the AC in this building it's not
you might turn it up and down one degree
but that's not how it works either on or
it's off freezing or hot as
yep uh Oliver continues what I have
picked up from Colleen is that she
wanted to start vlogging again but felt
like she couldn't Vlog again without
apologizing first so she just got it out
of the way as quickly and as vaguely as
possible she didn't apologize because
she wanted to I mean exactly that's
pretty much exactly nailed it she needs
to individually address the different
things she has done not just say she's
sorry for everything and move on that's
not taking accountability she's avoiding
it that's so true I mean and again take
it as a person who's got a 10 out of 10
perfect score from the uh well
celebrated and
illustrious
um Psych PS olist in
Seattle that's exactly what I said too
Oliver I co-signed that with you my
friend psychologist in Seattle yeah
that's I think it's something like that
psychology in Seattle yeah something
like that is it Frasier Dr Frasier Crane
yeah oh maybe that's a reference to I
don't
know but um have we have we watched that
on the show before I don't know if we've
ever I think you watched it on CU next
Tuesday or something it's worth the
watch I don't think we actually watched
it yeah bet maybe youth think Klein
Channel you did
did I I don't know if I did I think I
made the apology on the Ethan Klein
Channel I see but uh it wasn't I didn't
think it would be in good taste to
immediately follow it up with my perfect
apology
right M I'm
sorry oh God it's still on love the AC
the AC is still on no I don't care it's
F good but I took my jacket off that
turns me
on I'm cold now damn it jack it off work
with
me all right uh we love you
Oliver sorry about all this some
we need some account I need
steps to know that Trent is not going to
interact with kids anymore I also do you
know like what the hell uh Becky who we
love and appreciate had this to
say um I don't know if I if I was call
in and I was sorry I would probably
delete the ukulele video and donate all
the money from it that's just me so um I
don't believe she made money from the
ukulele video as far as we can tell I
think she should take it down taking it
down though
is probably the right thing to do cuz
she's calling all of why would you want
it up why would you want it up there's
no reason like leaving it up is standing
behind what you said in it I think she's
maybe just really proud of the musical
achievement I mean it is I mean we saw
it had 20 million views or something it
shook the world shook the world it was
it was a moment uh but yeah I mean it it
like you said is basically a video of
her accusing a bunch of people of being
Liars so I don't know how you can be
sincere about an apology now if uh
that's a good point she's like I'm so
sorry to everybody anyway guys watch my
last upload where I call them all
Liars right she uh Becky continues
trying to apologize while that video
making fun of grooming and fart jokes is
still up girl what are you doing well
said this video is articulated so well
and sums up all my feelings perfectly
she's talking about Adam's uh video um
she is going to continue her career and
we can't change that but this time so
much information is available for the
public endless videos screenshots
articles from Hope profile news outlets
and more most importantly I am always
sending all my love to Adam Oliver Alex
Ella Josh April and all the weenies
worldwide and countless others The
Bravery each and every one of you has
demonstrated has inspired me to be a
better person none of this was in vain
and I'm proud of you all I no definitely
wasn't in vain not at
all yeah that's beautiful not at all not
at all wait I don't know who Ella is
Ella um was one of Colleen's ex- fans
who is terminally ill and Colleen uh was
speaking to Johnny I think and Johnny
released the text where Colleen was like
she's not really sick she just wants to
be friends with me oh so up
I remember now that's nuts and Johnny
even uh posed that Colleen had written
characters after okay okay okay so
so she so she's okay let me read
this before I comment so Ella says I'm
not going to talk about it besides
saying this because it hurts but
honestly if she wanted to she could
contact people she hurt and apologize
and maybe take it I mean contact her for
Christ's sake literally literally that's
so messed up I honestly love to hear
from her privately that she knows she
hurt me
deeply uh if she doesn't care for me
enough to do that that's also fine
honestly at this point I'm kind of
indifferent but don't prevent pretend it
was a while ago and doesn't matter last
thing I'll say I pray to God no one ever
feels the need to be my friend because
of my illness my personal life these
illnesses have actually impeded my
relationships and I have suffered
immensely as a result
being chronically ill has destroyed my
life and to know that someone I admired
so greatly alleged alleged allegedly
thought my fight wasn't genuine ripped
my heart out it still does if you take
anything away from this please let it be
that being kind is the greatest thing
you can do for
someone if you don't like someone that
is fine but don't string them along for
years it's fine to not like
everyone that's actually being very
human I have people who don't don't like
me and it's not a problem anyways be
strong
guys love to her so much love if anybody
doesn't want to be your friend because
you're sick them are you kidding
you seem like such a beautiful person
but not even that to talk
yeah to say you're faking your illness
oh man that's up oh my God that's
crazy
dude love to Ella sending love so
much we're sending love
like droves yeah everybody's doing this
to their screen right now Ella everybody
at home everyone watching let's get
those fingers up for El we love you much
we love you you're very special you're
very
special and for the record I don't think
you're
line agree not even Brave to say it's a
brave it's a bra
I think you're not I don't you
know thank
you sof and then which one was s again
what was her
story sof was uh just super involved in
the fandom and I included some of their
Tweets in the in the first and they uh
they were in group chats I think but not
one got
it um do I start from the bottom any of
those are just ideas that I I agreed
with
my dad really said if Colleen has time
to film a video she has time to pay us
back for her Miranda shows hilarious
it's crazy because why didn't Colleen
reach out to Adam Becky and Oliver to
personally apologize she really should
have done
that that would have made a that would
have been a night that would have made a
difference I feel like I think it would
have made a huge
difference go ahead sorry because Adam
said from the beginning Colleen and
Corey if I get a private apology I will
not say anything else and this was
before he released screenshots this is
before everything he said if you say you
are sorry to me I will stop everything
he said that with his first
video she still won't so powerful just
to get that acknowledgement you
know um self continues she just wanted
happy birthday on her she wanted happy
birthday wishes the biggest Miracle is
Colleen uploaded a vlog without
exploiting her kids well that didn't
last long as we understood two whole
days nice I'm hot again bro damn dog I
go turn it on no no it's okay you can
leave it off I'm usually I run cold
usually so it's probably because you're
icky defitely Kaka I have fart gash in
my eyeballs yeah you're farting out your
eyes now dude it's coming out your ears
Fu got a little stink Cloud hovering
around you I'm like Pig Pen yeah just a
non farts just
farts all right so this is the last one
yeah so wait I want to watch the new one
now you want to watch your new Vlog
that's breaking I'll grab it that's
absolutely Bo big news oh
boy
okay
Colleen Did you see how skinny she is
girl I hope she's okay physically did
you see
all right so here is um her new
Vlog the like ratio is getting better
for her 6,000 up 4,000
down yes girl 40,000 in two hours
definitely on track to break 100,000
easy
yeah let's see
Bor that's you
Mommy what she's her kids voice in the
intro yeah she always did I think she
revamped it because before um when her
baby did it he couldn't say the words as
clearly the only time I ever use sounds
of my
kids is like Theodore for example I
would never use a sound bite of him
right Zach what the right okay
maybe that
one but it's not I'm not trying to sell
anything except my kid being
cool but I don't need to sell I don't
need to sell that speaks for itself
someone says I have
sultisz let me see don't look it up soul
don't look it up for itis let me tell
you what it is I don't think that's a
real
thing
sultisz I found it and it says that you
got stinky stinky ass stinky ass poop
mouth dude lame stinky death cancer yeah
actually when I was lit reading about
like what's the deal with the sulfur
burps what does it mean one of the
results was um you know it can me in a
whole broad range of things from you
know eating something bad to having a
gallbladder cancer you know like it's
like you you sons of
yeah you
all right col in what do you got
morning everybody it's time to check on
the chicken chick chicki
[Music]
got a lot to do today oo the lighting
sorry about that it should be a fun
filled day we are always crazy a you got
chicken she did that the spry
sound position we are always crazy oh
that was sick that was funny nice wait
that was super funny I want to hear that
again can you find a sound like that
Zach sure whenever I stand up or
anything the light
it should be a fun fil day week are
always
crazy that was
so oh I'm living for that a you got
chicken poo on me I'm going to change
positions this
life I am that's what it's that's what
it sounds like when I burp
yeah so tired today my kids have never
been good sleepers but Wesley became a
good sleeper like he would sleep through
the night he would fall he loved to go
to sleep he'd grab his blankie and be
like ni night be so excited I'm
not trying to fast forward the
internet's not
really not happening today face
yeah come on
now come on
now just let
it just let it Let It
Go anybody ever wondered what it was
like to use the internet
2001 I remember it's a little like
this sounds
horrible all right uh I feel like it
actually bugged out you might need to
refresh the uh YouTube
page all right feel weird Vlog again
what the is that I un full screen
it and then it works what the that
make any sense bro I'm pissed about
people are going to watch it talking
that I did it like
I'm one of fure three years what is this
probably not making any sense but I'll
try to find one of the first Vlogs I did
when I was like vlogging for myself I
have to jump in here it's future me
editing past me can we just talk about
how I'm ripping the crust off of my
peanut butter and jelly like I am a
three-year-old God that is so funny how
I realized that I do that or I that like
I was watching going like wait so funny
for that what am I doing what are you
doing girl I'll try to find that is so
silly outrageous girl you should make my
sandwiches I don't like the crust so she
edits her videos so she added that
boingy sound Cory used to edit her Vlog
so I guess it seems like she is editing
now though he's fired I don't know I'm
curious to find out he was forced to
find his own
spot one of the first Vlogs I did when I
was like taking CR off what are you
doing does anyone still take the crust
off their sandwiches no eat that
the crust one of the best
parts at the end sometimes I take it off
take it off what sometimes I don't
always I like it both ways it's it's
extra real estate that I don't need to
deal with if you're trying to if you're
trying to cut calories that that could
be a good option that's true yeah you
know get rid of the
crust girl you are so silly for doing
that I am buying it hold on this is
future me what were you thinking I'm
hanging out with my chickens we have
some very exciting news my chickens have
started laying eggs oh my gosh this is
an old clip that she included is that
what chickens do yeah they don't they
like lay an egg a day that's like the
what they do yeah we breathe chickens
lay eggs yeah yeah I've never seen her
do this she's like laying in the dirt so
weird I think she's just sunbathing but
looks so weird she's like
literally
and now goes in the oven for 25
minutes those
hurt oh my God that couch G me
[Music]
flashbacks
okay and there we have it ladies and
gentlemen everyone else let's go welcome
back Colleen
uh close I'm curious to
see curious to see what happens with her
um her Channel frankly you know morbidly
curious it's
interesting I mean fidus would you what
would you advise her to do as kind of a
seasoned
YouTuber uhh probably was very very cool
right one thing though when I was with
you I was thinking oh yeah in the future
I will be less I mean it's me it's FAS
and what do I want do I don't want what
would your advice be to her though and
it's kind of crazy how far
Society ideal cab is and
myidea what would you be your advice to
Callen if is true or not I'm if I'm 100%
truth right but I don't want to live
with a person I will be married to it
and when you understand I'm not saying
that this is what would your advice be
to call F I'm true to say to do this and
if he's respectful to the get I would be
M or whatever to all right all right
right right thank you thank you God damn
uh no no more thank you and Boogie if
she was forced to if people stop
watching and she needs to go to get job
go get a job do you have any advice for
her on how to do a good this is the
woman
who and I'm also a
pedophile oh well just cut straight to
the chase huh okay yeah no that's good
it's No Nonsense I like
that um so that's Colleen I guess that's
it fall Vlog what I've been up to we've
seen all
these yeah I think I think her she's
going to settle around 100 th we after
like a couple weeks couple more weeks we
could check in I think they're still
looky L yeah I'm a liil l that's what
I'm say I'm GNA I'll claim it I'm a look
Lou I don't like being a liil l what's a
look Lou what's a Lou why
Lou um L's the goat I know what a luil
Lou is but who's Lou it's not it's l o o
not l o u luy l just like a silly kind
of like liy Lou I'm lookie looky Lou
lookie Lou let's see if there is history
here uh what's what's Mariam Webster
what's my boy Mariam got to say uh first
known use in
1977 it said it says the first known use
of liy L was in 1977 but doesn't say
where or why who did what what's the
point of that entry then wow Miriam
Webster idiot loser more like change
your name to that usually doesn't let me
down like that Miriam Webster oh ass
Miriam what a is your dad uh is he back
already or no yeah he just landed the
hawk yep the hawk has landed the hawk is
back in the nest he had a good visit I
hope oh yeah great and he's very
thankful for everyone being nice and
stuff like that he really really like to
be like being here that was nice it was
nice having him here it's nice to meet
him I liked him everybody miss him the
fans the crew me too maybe we can get
him to migrate over next H yeah let's
get
him I mean you know is he is he
single yeah yeah he's single so he does
does he have anything new Bachelor does
does he have anything keeping him there
other than his
job no probably not that's what I'm
saying he could probably just get a
normal work visa honestly well he needs
someone to sponsor right right but if
you get married for example then once
you're married then you can petition to
bring your family over yeah that's I'm
going to try to do that then let's do
that let's get Hawk over your sta oh
yeah dude he's going to fly over here
it's a whole new life out here for him
I'll get my whole family out here let's
bring him that's it you're the anchor
baby yeah that's
right all right so there's that thank
you we'll talk about Pokey cookies and
then I think I have to go because I'm I
um hot and diares I threw up a
pole and uh
only 7% of the audience cuts off the
crust every time I sometimes
26% sometimes and a full 67% never cut
off the crust thank you I I felt like I
was crazy cuz all of you were saying you
cut off the crust sometimes but my take
is in the majority here with the
audience most of the time I do not cut
the crust okay the vast it's just an
occasional it's just because when I
prepare sandwiches for the kids
sometimes I'll feel they ain't about the
crust the kids see it's you know it's
easier to eat yeah when you're trying to
feed a kid you want to Stack the odds in
your favor okay got it as much as
possible understood yeah you know but
Grandpa was feeling a little frisky
today cut the crust
off all right so there's a whole big
controversy stewing around friend of the
show Pokey man who we love no cookies
for you has everybody been following
this um super high level
[Music]
drama I kind of want to do a poll before
I start talking about it
[Music]
um of people that are following
this let's have three
options okay
one Pokey messed
up big time Pokey messed up I don't want
to do I don't want to qualify too much
poke messed up no big time no two it's
not it's not that
serious or three I'm not following the
drama so you can abstain if you really
want to participate or if you want to
see the results for pizza's
sake
um so let's see I'm curious where
the I'm curious where the consensus is
here
okay
here we
go the poll is going
up this music is so tense everybody get
your oh man here we go get your votes in
now okay okay pretty interesting spread
here as the votes come in this I've seen
this guy sent a few messages call Ethan
or Olivia did you get my email I troll
politicians like Matt Gates and Mike
Pence IRL I I wouldn't get your
email did you get an email from
professional
douche I was just telling you about it
this morning actually I did you were mhm
was it good apparently on a an episode
of leftovers Hanan like pulled him up
for you oh is it good I didn't I didn't
look into it I was just looking at it
with a name like that how could it be
bad so
true all right so going to the uh
results we have 20% saying poke messed
up actually can we can we do some math
here if we eliminate the 44% that says
I'm not following the
drama you end up with more of
a maybe a 6040 almost like what's the
spread here amongst CU it say 20% poke
messed up 35% not that
serious you know what I mean how would
you express
those as a function of 100 oh well uh
it's fairly close to 50% so you could
just double those numbers it's not
exactly but 40 to 70 that doesn't add up
that doesn't add up yeah but uh
25% things should messed up how much 25%
right no it's more than that it's more
than that I think it would be like 30 or
35 or maybe even 40 it's 20 21
if it's it's more than half I can see
that okay I think I know how to do it
one sec Dan is crunching the numbers
thank you to all the gifted memberships
from
Chloe we love Chloe thank you appreciate
that a
lot thank you thank
37.5% for the Pokey messed up so that
that's pretty significant I'm kind of
Sur about a third so about two3 I would
say about two3 than a third yeah a
little bit more than a third all right
so let's talk about it and then we can
kind of see what everybody's thinking
here so Pokey
man put out a cookie called the Mina
cookie I actually got some of the uh
what do you call it when you get stuff
cuz you're the pr package yeah the pr
cookies for you when you get free stuff
cuz you're
rich funny how that works oh yeah uh I
got the pr package pretty nice they're
nice cookies um they taste like they're
oh my God Asis and Ray relax they taste
like they're healthy and what I mean by
that is not good no no no they taste
good but not as good as like a Keebler
crunch or whatever right chips aoy it
tastes like a little different but it's
good it's definitely a nice snack
question it's like a gluten-free
vegan uh style cookie I don't even know
is it gluten-free I think it's it's all
of those things and more and more yeah
gluten-free non GMO is it
vegan cuz that would mean no eggs which
would definitely impact taste would
probably
be I think it let me see it says deep
Cho it says gluten-free no GMO no I
don't think it is okay so maybe not
vegan you guys know how I feel about GMO
I Am pro GMO right I I love GMO I say
genetically modify everything including
these burps out of my mouth I
wish I was
GMO you might
be I
might at this point with all those GMOs
you're consuming maybe it's
Rewritten your DNA just like the fiser
vaccine that was about to say that true
all so she DNA history what is that term
uh DNA history
um I don't know
Chernobyl ch ch Shola Shola
oh man P prolapse penguin thank you for
the five Gifted Man appreciate that a
lot thank you you know what I'm talking
about
right Shola or some something here's all
the uh promises uh that they make here
GMO free nothing
artificial good source of vitamin D
gluten-free plant-based wait plant-based
implies vegan then why would they say
Vegan though what's the ingredients list
uh I think we have it right here one
second wait plant could it be plantbased
and not vegan grain free
okay is that the same thing as
glutenfree uh I don't know what the
difference is there that's a lot of
things not in it what is in
this one thing I will say is that okay
here I'll say she says it's finally here
introducing my new company minus snacks
I could never find the perfect healthy
snack that tasted good so I made one for
us the midnight mini cookies are made
with real non-GMO ingredients plus added
vitamin D treat yourself at minus
snacks.com
all right let's take a look let's hop on
over to
mina Cool
website look at all those cookies you
can't hold them all yeah is that
intentional spread them
around it looks just like the I can't
hold all these things yeah exactly can't
hold all this salad right or she's meing
with that I
assume uh here's our story um oh who's
the
lady Our Story begins with Pokey and
Darcy Darcy that's Darcy thanks AB I got
you lovers of snacks devotees of quality
food this this shared passion was met
with an equally shared frustration that
the snacks they loved the most often
made them feel the worst well yeah so
they set out on a journey to create the
most cravable poppable feel-good snacks
of all time real ingredients sustainably
sourced vitamin D no gluten on gml
nothing artificial better snacks makes
us happy so we made them to share with
you can I say something as a
nutritionist as a somewhat of a amateur
nutritionist very
nutritious I don't think that any of
this means that it's good for
you real ingredients sustainably sourced
vitamin D no gluten non GMO nothing I
mean it could still be very unhealthy
and be all those
things it's true but a lot of people you
know are concerned about one thing on
that list or multiple things on the list
I'm not I'm not saying that hers is
unhealthy I don't I haven't looked at
the ingredients but yet we'll do it but
what I can say is
um a lot of Health Foods Market
themselves as healthy under these
pretense and they're actually I think
it's can be quite detrimental to Public
Health because people will overly
[Music]
um they'll they're overindulge in in
snacks that are right calories that they
think are healthy have tons of sugar and
are not healthy at all it's the same
it's like literally the same thing as
eating a chips aoy yeah and I guess
there's a aspect of just there should be
some degree of Common Sense here that if
you're eating a cookie it's probably not
as healthy as some alternative snacks
that you could be eating but if you are
going to indulge maybe this is a better
option right it's a healthy a keer right
yeah well listen Pizza can be very
nutritious so why can't a
cookie true I learned that years ago
from a very is actually very nutritious
disgraced business I learn that that's
how I ended up 50 I've had over 40
pizzas in the last 30 days but that
being said I haven't looked at her
ingredients so maybe it's true of uh of
her product I'm getting sources tell me
that um the sugars and macros are pretty
good let's see I remember looking and
thinking seven cookies is 140 calories
that's a pretty good
snack and not a lot of
um calories yeah 140 calories they're
small they're small but that's that's
good I mean how many calories is an
Oreo oh I don't know probably more than
140 right they are small but that that's
a good point like how does it compare to
Oreos Oreo three Oreos is the serving
and that's 160 so you can eat seven of
these for 140 it's definitely way lower
cow than like a a full force cookie you
could do it by Gram 28 grams how much is
in three how much grams is three Oreos
uh the
it doesn't say what are you seeing yeah
they didn't translate seven cookies 28
gr the thing I'm looking at say how much
grams is one how much does one Oreo
grams is one
Oreo 11.3
gr 11.3 G
yeah but is the yeah so one cookie is
11.3 so three or three would be 33
almost 30 34 gram yeah so it's more yeah
and three three Oreos has how many
calories what was it 160 160 so wait
this doesn't have less calories than
Oreos does
it per gram per per gram yeah but per
like cookie per gram is what matters
though isn't it well I guess it just
depends on how look at it I don't know
how many cookies you want to eat yeah
also who either eats three
Oreos three you're saying people eat
more than
that that's a lot I don't know three
Oreos is a bit it's a big sorry come on
now when you go and you get a glass of
milk and some Oreos you're taking three
that was literally my breakfast had like
Oreos is maybe a littleit too much I
mean I'm I'm grabbing four or five at
least no I'll buy I'll buy a or Oreo
package and eat it like a bag of ships
I'll eat till there's nothing left yeah
who three or like that's a joke okay
fair enough and I whereas seven I feel
like that's a more
realistic suggested serving side I've
eaten these cookies and I put seven
aside and it it it fulfilled me yeah I
was fulfilled right mm fill that bag up
I was fulfilled that bag up so the
ingredients is gluten-free flour blend
almond flour CA flour coconut flour palm
oil
coconut sugar white chip and
Barbados coconut powder agave syrup
soluble tapioca fiber vanilla extract
baking soda sea salt natural
flavors and mushroom
powder sounds
delish okay mushroom
powder um so let's see it's
got uh what I don't see on there is eggs
so I guess it is vegan okay they should
say that then I think that's a good
selling point they're vegan maybe
there's something in there that is like
produced in the same facility as
something that isn't vegan so they can't
technically call it that yeah maybe
maybe
so um but okay it looks I mean for a
cookie it seems fine there's a lot of
well eight
grams says total sugar 8 gram includes
eight added sugar that just means eight
grams right not
pretty I don't know how those break down
it doesn't seem that
bad for cookies so there's that okay
we're getting we haven't gotten to why
people are angry
yet
[Music]
um yada yada let's go to the document
and
see
so what's the price it's for an eight
pack four pack is 28 bucks
which is
$7 per pack yeah yeah seven bucks per
pack oh Pokemon is in chat she said the
vegan requires certification oh pokey's
in chat hey what
up um well there you go so it is vegan
are you I wonder if you'll get the
certification I feel like people like
that it's vegan plant-based though so
the um the chat I put up a poll took it
upon myself well initiative here for cl
and uh three or less Oreos is only 20%
of the I'm a three or less guy
personally well you I don't know what to
say I'm a former 270,000
pounder 270,000
all right I got a pro I have an Oreo
problem you don't know what it's like
all right I want Push Oreos they're very
rich you know it's very sweet it's very
decadent yeah like now Famous
Amos that's Bing well who's Darth though
I just got the story but I don't know
who's Darcy she's a former Kellog uh
executive she's been in the industry for
15 years where'd you read that I
searched
it I want I need more info about Darcy
pokey pokey in chat just said um crew
Ethan if you guys have uh questions you
can ask me directly okay
great so who's Darcy girl I want to know
more about Darcy she looks professional
I like her vibes M darc seed
out so um let's
see the first product is Midnight
Cookies which we just talked about it's
$28 for a four pack $7 per bag I don't
know how much I mean that seems like
maybe a little more expensive than usual
but I don't know how much is a pack of
like chips
aoy pack
of
chips aoy
MBE chips aoy
is uh I mean it's five bucks this is on
Walmart where they sell everything like
let's look at
uh what the it says was $12 now is
five what do you
mean what the does that mean how
can it be how can that be true I'm
seeing $5 five bucks so it's it's it's
really it makes sense it's a healthy
product it's a little more expensive and
also it's a kind of a boutique product
it's it's not like something that's
mass-produced on the level of chips aoy
right also go buy like some you know
healthy cookies from uh Whole Foods how
much are those 89 let's see
Whole Foods healthy cookies getting an
idea
here Whole Foods Market healthy
cookies
um I don't know what the this is
doesn't look that healthy though
is there no
price come on Whole
Foods what are you doing you need me to
put my zip I'm not going to put my zip
here K it I'm just going to put a random
one yeah I just typed the random la1
doesn't mean anything don't even try bro
use current location that'd be suck
that'd be sick I'm just clicking this
address
unrelated 530 this is this is not
healthy this is just a random
cookie and it's not a lot
either Pokey said also chat I know the
comment I made was distasteful and
apologize for it but absolutely did not
say it towards my fans Community it was
a bad joke towards one rude person
harassing me in chat thank you pokey I
will we will get to
that absolutely
absolutely
um I kind of curious though if we can
find can you try to find one so you just
find me a healthy Whole Foods
cookie I don't think it's more than that
so um people started to compare the
Mina's Midnight Cookies to another brand
totes which has midnight mini cookies
that I think were on sale at
Costco MH here they are this is the
first I
guess
controversy fear but said pokem me's new
product is apparently just a rebranded
totsi midnight mini cookie which she
sells for three times the price the only
difference between the cookie is vitamin
D3 28 versus $10 for 400 gram
okay
um let's see
here I think I think oh I kind of want
to see the ingredients though because
this is all pretty generic is the
ingredients the same well she clarifies
later on in a tweet that they work
together yeah we should you should check
out the next link which is her
explanation which makes it she says her
their recipe is proprietary and look at
you cannot tell from this if it's
proprietary or not I mean cookies all
use the same ingredients more or
less you see can you show the
ingredients list but anyway let's keep
moving
um totsy cookies yeah we talked about
that or $10 a
bag for 14 ounces and minus is $7 for 4
ounces ingredients are similar except
for the addition of vitamin D pokei
posted a detailed explanation here's her
explanation by the way the reason I'm
even talking about this because it might
seem silly to a lot of you guys who
don't know about it is that there is so
much people losing their God
damn mind over this cookie controversy
and it's the same people that lose her
mind anytime she does anything
it's so dumb
yeah well I'm try listen I'm trying I'm
trying to be you know I'm not I'm trying
to be uh partial here
um uh uh in my
analysis but she
says but yes the the outrage is far
reaching I mean even even my dear friend
uh who I love so well I'm a huge fan of
everything he does Charlie
penguin made a really enlightened video
about the topic I see a lot of people
don't like eth it's totally fine you
don't have to like everyone or anything
yeah I get that that's fair that's fair
that's fair Pokemon situation is
horrible he says it's horrible you guys
Pokemon situation Pokemon situation with
a picture of what is this thumbnail dude
do you even try are you even
trying wait is that really no that's his
thumbnail no that is that just freeze
frame on no that's his thumbnail bro
it's literally not even centered of her
webcam huh yeah well no but he's
great um he did a really good uh I've
kept a naughty little secret got five
million views he's kept a naughty secret
from all of you for the last three weeks
and I time stamps they dock okay good so
I'll just do from that
so yeah that's why I'm talking about
this is just because of the the size of
the uh of the outrage would definitely
suggest that there's something really
big happening here so let's continue
um here's her detailed
explanation no that's not it here's her
post one more time thank you thank you
peace and love here we go all right so
she said um there's been some confusion
about the product I launched and I'm
here to set the record
straight pokem man's new products
apparently just a this is the photo we
showed already so here's her response
the batch of mina cookies we're
currently shipping were made 3 weeks ago
they're not a drop ship product and we
own our formula the cookies they are
that are being made compared to were
also made by our manufacturer creation
foods which specializes in healthy food
the compared cookie had one test batch
sold before they were retired months
later we partner with creation foods and
fell in love with the flavor profile of
the midnight
cookie we then decided to work together
to refine and improve the formula and
were really happy with the final product
while the ingredient list may look
similar they are entirely different in
terms of ingredients quality uh quality
ratios sourcing size texture of the
cookies and uh the added vitamin D
refining formulas is a very very common
practice in the food industry plus
around 70 to 80% of the foods you see in
the grocery store are white
labeled so is she saying it's a white
label she's she owns the recipe now she
bought it from them and refined sounds
like she just it's not a white label it
sounds like it's just her recipe yeah
she she liked it she bought it there was
a a test batch of cookies that was sold
at Costco I don't think it did well
enough for them to continue it as like a
wide product or whatever some or poten
eventually I guess pokei you're here so
you can answer or maybe they approached
him and said hey we want to buy this
recipe I don't know she she said in chat
we own the recipe now bought it and we
refined it so there you go did she buy
it because was the cookie off the market
or on the market when she bought the
recipe not that it matters it was
definitely off the market cuz it
was yeah okay from what we've looked
into it but I guess she not when can I
eat eggs again when can you eat eggs
again
what did you what am I looking at what
did you do what I smashed it up why' you
do that stop yourself from eating them
cuz I'm hungry like a giant baby but I
can't eat
eggs why can't you eat eggs bro because
I have puke eggs coming from my
and mouth what the I need
time I can't just go to eggs I need time
I need to rra it up it's egg salad what
do you want it's actually kind of a good
way to mix egg salad put a little
mayonnaise in there call yourself sh a
good
time I just you know how hard it is to
mix up that with a fork look how
fast I did
that and argue with results
yeah it's good stuff smells like my
innards Pokey says she believes it's all
it was off Market okay yeah which me and
Dan sat here yesterday and researched
quite a bit and we did not find any
place you could have bought those
cookies for at least like seven months
okay yes the test batch was seven was a
while ago yeah there's a hardcore Costco
community that documents every new
product that they have there is what I
discovered on the uh oh really yeah let
me see if I can find that again cuz that
was really funny I was like I was like
why it was totally unrelated to any of
this controversy 7 months ago on a
subreddit there was a photo of those
other cookies and they were like has any
anybody tried these yet oh they dropped
these new cookies mhm Costco fans man I
don't know Costco heads Costco heads
that's what you do when you're like
basically you know if you're retired
your kids are gone you become a Costco
head sure or maybe before that you know
sounds nice is that a Facebook group
where do we where do we meet with other
Costco heads I'm going to look for
it are you eating the eggs now oh did
you find
it no it's pear think this is it I'm on
that uh dirty Joe diet what's his name
Rick
Ross yeah here you go six months ago
onco so Reddit dirty Joe is he fat Joe's
cousin dirty Joe what did you find Dan
this is the post so six months ago Joe
and I think this is the same photo from
that tweet so they must have found they
dug this up huh they dug this up anybody
try these worth buying
comments and I didn't see anyone else
mentioned isn't costu one of those uh
membership things cuz people were
comparing the price to this place they
make cheaper cuz they
people aren't subscribing you
have to pay a yearly fee right to get
those good de but these are $10 a bag
it's hot barer they're
bigger it it it it but still it's like
not a fair comparison yo there's a half
a million members in this
Costco show me what's a big deal dude
wait hold on show me what's on Costco
right now sort by top of the month let
me see what they talk
about I need to know if I need to get in
this community or what they got two
times as many people in their Community
as we do 21,000 up votes for but they
did The Coming to America yeah oh that's
awesome that's great let me see what
else we got going on there uh one hour
$100 Costco meal prep that looks like a
good ass meals
boy might be careful though I see sulfur
farts coming out of
that look like the nachos oh yeah see
that for sure some real nasty ones not
Parts though burs yeah
yeah um we also have impossible patties
wait hold go up sold for $10 go up when
the rotisserie chicken comes out go up
above that
one uh one the
fresh let me get that one comes the
chicken so do people fight over the
rotisseries oh they're all lined up
baby those are go oh everybody has their
arms crossed they are good what yo
they're like zombies dent it's an event
in Costco bro every day and you know the
chicken is better than others when the
lid is a little raised up because you
know it's a thicker juicier chicken what
the how do you know that they do this oh
yeah dude it's about how they know
when it comes out there's a certain time
that they they're lined up they know the
schedule chickens for the they're on
yeah you got to hang out on this Reddit
to so if you go to Costco and you want
one of these uh Birds you got to make
sure that the uh the lid is a little
raised dude they sold I'd be happy to
get anything well not me personally but
no it's goated that was gone in two
seconds5 I don't think you're going to
be able to be selective this chicken
lived and died for five dollars
it's the best deal in town man brutal
you can't beat it Pokey left another
comment that I thought was insightful
she said not only uh are the Costco
memberships required but she says likely
trying to sell off inventory to get rid
of stock so that's also
fair you know anyway let me read her
message read the pricing making a
healthy quality snack with real
gluten-free ingredients and add of
vitamins is not cheap practice you been
following me for some time you know I
rarely take sponsorship because I try to
be mindful of promoting or endorsing
products that's me too I'm right there
with you I'm so
selective I haven't sold merch in years
I C my donations and frankly if I wanted
cash grab it'd be silly to do that
through a start up because they're
extremely unlikely to profit in the
first few years plus any profits we make
goes directly back into creating more
products people have been calling this
to crash cash grab
which does not really jive with me
considering what she's saying is
true about all the things that
she doesn't do that a lot of creators do
to make money but I can't imagine
selling cookies online is like the best
way to make money no just in terms of
like an idea mhm if you're like trying
if you're trying to do a cash grab
you're not going and making like healthy
Boutique cookies sold online only you
looked into doing a product and like the
amount of like FDA stuff turn you off to
it right it was like too complicated
well also I ended up just deciding that
it wasn't a good idea at all okay well
there's that too there's a whole bunch
but it was but it my point being it's
much easier to sell shirts right then
sell a food
product it's not about the ease it's
just about the it's like not a huge
vertical mhm it's like if you're trying
to make money you're not going to go
make Boutique cookies and sell them
online it's not like a massive vertical
who got rich doing that
ever right I mean it's a passion project
Mr kebler I guess is the only one yeah
he's been in the game for a while and I
don't and those guys do AR Shady those
elves yeah yeah don't trust
don't trust anybody that lives in a
tree um something off there no I
kill squirrels on site what no you don't
I'm kidding I love squirrels Dan sorry
cam Dan just got me all hyped up on
killing tree dwellers leave the
squirrels alone I will I said live in a
tree not on a tree I have no problem
living on a tree that's cute and
adorable but if you you have like a
little house in there well how do you
define in cuz they have have you seen
what these seen their house yeah I know
but squirrel's probably
like you mean they has to have a door
and yeah like full-blown dude like
look at this look at this what's the
matter with
this they killed that tree cam that's
does that tree look dead to you D that
Tre is not it's artificial they stapled
these on I hear they make map in
there it's a
front yeah some sort of front it's like
little spoiler Hermanos right the
cookies are just a cover Gus is the uh
Powerhouse behind it Gus one of them's
names is Gus Gustavo Gustavo the elf
yeah anyway she continues um oh I
already read it so yeah I mean I I
believe her just because
again if you're going to do a cash grab
there's uh pretty much every way is
better than to make a boutique online
only Health cookie I'm not saying you
can't get rich but I'm saying something
like that takes a lot of time so you got
to build a brand I mean this is
something
that is a stretch still in my opinion to
get rich from but even if you were this
is definitely a long-term
move uh so that's my opinion on that
thank
you moving
on
um Pokey responds to the price of her
cookies on stream saying okay so this is
I guess when is this when it started to
really PE piss people off I mean I guess
everyone was talking about it before but
I guess this clip started going
viral and
uh all the yeah I mean I I wasn't
following it super closely through the
weekend but you know that that
explanation that she gave that was last
week right um and after I read that I
was like that that's a perfectly
reasonable explanation and I guess I
incorrectly assume that that would
probably be the end of it um
but I guess she was still getting hanged
about it all weekend so so here is the
clip that um changed the the world as we
know it here she is when people are like
oh my God $28 for
cookies it's four
bags that's seven $7 a bag I know I know
math is
hard when you're an idiot but
like if you're a broke boy just say so
any when people so like okay so again to
read her statement on that she said
um what did she say did we have it in
yeah number eight in the dog no what did
she leave in
chat um she said also chat no the
comment I made was distasteful and I
apologized for it but I absolutely did
not say towards my fans SL Community it
was a bad Jo joke towards one rude
person harassing me in chat there's what
to say about Pokey I mean we know that
she gets and she gets a lot of from
everything she does on the Internet it's
been kind of a history of that
um
and I don't blame her for being a little
defensive you know I mean it's not the
best way to handle it but it's also not
that big of a deal I mean she
[Music]
says people you're chilling
yo this is not a coverup I'm talking
about
it dude she was Anno people were
annoying her online nonstop about some
cookies she streams how long
every day she made one little
comment and then people lost their
goddamn mind they're like oh now we have
something to use now we have the clip
people are people are saying Play the
full clip is there a full clip with
context I'm
missing let me I mean that's
the she's being she's being sassy and uh
you know
obviously calling people poor is not
funny but um but uh whatever I mean okay
if you if you think it's not nice and
that's fair then that's fine um I mean
it's a bad call to say that just purely
in the sense of like I mean look what's
happened now like that is like that's
giving right and Amo to your
haters but I mean I'm sure she's aware
of that and that's why she said she
apologized so here is
uh let's
[Music]
see
um she clarified it was a
joke this person Chase
said this has to be a joke Pokey there
are people that work extremely hard
daily doing jobs most would consider not
as fun as streaming there are better
ways to word this this is damaging not
only to you but those who are in
business with you and this cookie I mean
okay
that's a criticism that's I
think I don't think that's hedged in a
way that it doesn't seem that I don't
know it's not that bad he's not being
like totally vicious and a total dick
about
it I don't think she was saying like
poor people are so lame e or anything
like that but no she's I guess you sorry
go ahead people are interpreting it that
way where she's like poor people who
can't afford my cookies get the
out but uh okay okay fine so she
responded to this guy she said while
what I said was 100% intended to be a
joke I can see why it came off as
insensitive and I apologize for that I
also understand the current price of the
cookies might be expensive for some and
promise will continue to consider
pricing to keep Mina as affordable as
possible also want to clarify that this
was said towards one route chatter I did
not at all intend for it to be a general
statement towards my
community um
that's fair I think she apologize and
you
know was this also a joke here's Boby in
the comments what did he
have to say sure he had something good
to
say she said this is the difference we
read this one this guy 12 said this
is so scummy man she is praying on her
stands ringing them out like a rag for
every last penny she's a manipulative
liar and will once again pull the woman
get treated unfairly and sex discard
again and her sheep fans will eat it up
she responded you're a dumbass who lacks
reading comprehensive skills so you
resort to regurgitating idiotic incel
rhetoric instead of easily reading up on
basic uh cpg food industry practices
here's what I'll say about
this if you think that
Pokey
is is uh hiding behind this term of
women women getting unfaired treated
unfairly or sexist or whatever if you
don't think that Pokey is unfairly
treated then tell me this why the
is Aiden Ross and train wreck and xqc
and all these actual scum pieces of
that advertise gambling solely
getting people literally addicted and
frankly statistically is going to be
responsible for people killing
themselves
why is it that Pokey selling cookies and
let's just look at it as the worth worst
Faith possible that she doesn't like
poor people that she
um I mean she didn't steal the recipe I
can't even look at it that way she she
she she took the recipe over let's say
she HS she hates poor people and it's a
total um a total
Shakedown why is she getting more
than these other three
scumbags that are selling their
soul literally to an online crypto
casino and nobody gives a
I mean on the same scale was there
this much kicked up over xqc doing
gambling again no absolutely not was
there this much over well I mean
there there was I mean we were giving
them about
that did um true did Charlie and His
Infinite Wisdom make any videos about
train wreck Aiden Ross or xqc gambling I
don't know I honestly don't know he may
have Charlie find out State gambling
penguin and and I by all means I do
think Charlie is one of the
highest uh moral Arbiters in the
internet today so I'm not trying to call
him out I do believe that everything he
says I see he has videos about it I
would have to watch it to see like what
his take on it I see he has a debate
with Hassan over gambling and kick and I
know what H stance is so he's debating
him that seems like he would be wait
Charlie's Pro gambling I I don't I'd
have to watch the video I don't want to
say that I just see the top result
Charlie debates hassabi over gambling
and kick and then again if you want to
talk about hating poor people people
thinks it's hilarious when
xqc when people go hey um when he posts
a monetized video of him doing soy face
over sqc reacta Israel air strike hits
Gaza Tower okay and then his response to
that criticism is AOS himself with
bricks of cash and a diamond watch then
this is funny and cool and we love this
and he's
based but then Pokey is a money hungry
greedy like don't you see them there
that there's just a such a
uh a disproportionate response here mhm
and what's funny is Nadia uh defended
pokem man she had a similar uh take that
you just did and then xqc commented on
that as well I I sent the link oh who's
Nadia Nadia the streamer um Call of Duty
we talked about her oh she's the girl
who people say she cheats
yes okay so she said uh you guys have
people like neon Jack sneo who average
thousands of viewers and do nothing but
spread negativity see I'm I even took I
think the gambling one is even a better
example but this is a good one too but
when she sees a girl selling cookies
that's when they all want to speak out
the immense hatred towards women on the
internet is
unhinged um and then xqc responds did
she even call xqc out so what the
is he even doing white nighting for his
home like for sneo okay go ahead yes
Nadia it is the hate towards women that
gave the cookies their price
tag so you're angry that it's expensive
you hypocrite loser so you
dumb that messaged me my my watch
is worth more than your house you're
upset that the cookies are overpriced
you dumb pandering misogynist
loser you hypocrite you
loser and again I'm not even I'm not
even defending Pokey like I can see
that she made mistakes here that are
worthy of criticism and I thought like
the one we read was fair but a lot most
of it is not fair and this one is just
obscene I mean talk about throwing rocks
from a glass house like dude she's
selling cookies you're literally getting
people mainlined into a gambling
addiction you
you coward you fool I mean these
people are the worst of the worst you
want to talk about net negative on
society it doesn't get worse than what
xqc Aiden Ross and train Rex does it
doesn't you might as well go sell
fentol I mean
seriously um at least you get something
for
fentanyl you know what I mean MH
gambling you get
nothing
me xqc says yes Nadia it is the hate
towards women that gave the cookies
their price coincidentally it is also
the hate towards women that made
everyone live paycheck to paycheck and
not afford to live luxury goods there's
no valid criticism here tell him Queen
you you
and then just to Pro have to buy
the cookies I mean yeah it's a it's a
treat right you can't afford it's a
premium product and again you you
literally posted
this and now you're like a champion of
the
normies the Common Man and how did you
make all this money it wasn't selling
cookies no it was selling the deadliest
Vice in the world gambling to a
unregulated crypto casino that
everybody knows is crooked as their
headquarters in kosel in a shed
two kids by the way kids on stake I'm
still I got a email the other
day with the account I signed up for the
show with with no registration
saying hey you you've been you
haven't used your account or whatever
like come gamble we got a bonus for you
right on yeah un identificated like
account and people who say that you
can't buy crypto underaged dude it's so
easy I've been doing it easy I sold CS
go Skins for crypto when I was 16 it's
super easy dude we proved it like you
said we had on the show yeah go sign up
don't tell them your age don't confirm
your age yeah and you were gambling yeah
and my account and we and we gambled yep
it's like so frustrating so
first of
all okay and then the fact that 20,000
people thought that this was a banger
tweet just proves to me how many virgin
incel women hating freaks that
are getting so up in arms over a goddamn
cookie Scandal and again I'm not saying
she didn't up there's there's
there's definitely criticisms to be had
here that she's acknowledged and
apologized for but this sentiment is
truly truly
demented truly demented the outsized re
action of this is
mind-bendingly insane get a load of this
God damn dude what an idiot what a
loser Jesus Christ to have the balls to
type that after all you've
done it's nuts look at this one
more time because it's hard to believe
he posted a video sequence of tweets is
so insane what he posted a video soy
facing over Israel air strikes hit Gaza
monetized
okay the text of the Tweet is when I
think about scum degenerate content
parasites look like I don't think I
could possibly create a parody more on
the nose than this Fair honestly I mean
look at the image disgusting yo
dude that was a JM for sure I'm kidding
doing a military analysis yeah but um
anyway
um here's his response
huh and we're angry and then we're angry
at poke man right just to be
clear
okay he says yeah I got paid from this
what's
up dude she's not selling like a cancer
drug or like insulin it's
cookies it's it's a luxury she's not
marked up insulin like Martin scarelli
or something so do we um we may have
gotone ahead of ourselves a little bit
we did we talk about the fact that that
the cookies are only available in packs
of four cuz that's the source of a lot
of the uh overpriced we did at the
beginning we said it's $7 a pack so $7 a
pack but you can only currently buy it
in packs of four via the website I
imagine if it gets distributed in stores
obviously you'll be able to buy
individual packs right yes yeah that's
what I assume as well someone said your
soul remains empty his response was your
bank account relates and once again
epic awesome dub sick so sick
where's Charlie's video about
xqc flexing his watch and Bricks of cash
on
literal civilians being blown
up I mean maybe he made
it I don't F him maybe he made it maybe
I'm jumping into conclusions because
Charlie is truly one of the greats
and he's never he just so right by
everything yeah love him I'm picking up
what you're putting down but but yeah I
don't I don't actually know so you
shouldn't say that he may he may have
sure may have criticized him for it yeah
he probably did he probably did make a
video about this yeah mhm
sure so let's
see Aiden's reaction oh God this
did not say about this Aiden Ross
you are literally okay hold on before I
respond let me watch this let me see
this guy dude please don't set
me off man I'm about to lose my mind
everyone just watch it I want to see
what your reactions are like oh my God
$28 for
cookies take off screen for a second
what happed we probably haven't checked
this is kick the chat there is his chat
oh true true so maybe I didn't see
anything I'll do it like this you can't
read the chat like this right if you
zoom in oh yeah just like this can you
read that
Ian
kick or I can just do like this Zoom
yeah yeah zoom in to Aiden there you go
perfect why did you do that God damn it
all right this is fine okay play like
that four bags bro that's seven $7 a bag
I know I know math is
hard when you're an idiot
but like if you're a broke boy just say
so okay so this backlash she's getting
is 100% her fault I would okay okay it's
her fault that's fine never get backlash
for this I swear to God y'all would not
give a flying oh yeah yeah no he's
right oh maybe we're about to get a good
aident take holy
uh everything okay over there no
Ian's R2D2 accidentally knocked Lego oh
[Music]
are you wait are you are you
serious right now uh did it get it
shattered it sounded like we can rebuild
it though right Ian yeah but he's been
working on this thing for
like can we get a shot of it what
happened it's my shaky hands I just got
so angry Aiden made me so
angry I had to throw it on the ground no
whatpp all yeah it doesn't it the damage
does not look that bad I think he'll be
okay oh no I had it in a precarious spot
that's my that's my bet how long have
you been working on that
R2-D2 H like a little bit at a time over
a few weeks probably oh God look at this
poor soul we need Luke Skywalker to come
fix him up that is very sad that's how
Luke found him I think at the Droid this
is not that bad yeah legol Lou the
doctor he can fix it up anyways sorry to
distress
oh no so anyway okay so wait Aden said
that he would not get for this so
my eyebrows are raised here let's see
it's your fault for setting up a libtard
community who cancels everything you do
and it's just
like I mean wait that's not who's
canceling her that doesn't make any
sense it's literally your fans dummy
yeah no this is the whole Ben Shapiro uh
we don't believe in cancel culture
around here right well but at the same
time he's being more graceful than these
other fools
I mean he was right about the fact that
his audience would clearly not give a
if he said something like that I
watched twitch a decent amount I'm sure
most of the streamers I've watched has
made a poor joke within the this
previous month seriously everyone I mean
Dam hello and it does not become a viral
Twitter story like God damn it's it
wasn't that bad it was distasteful I
agree but I feel like I've probably made
a joke like that in the past I I'm not
even going to lie I wouldn't even say is
I mean I understand that it might not be
a good move because now they got the
clip but I mean that's the thing if
there's one person annoying
[Music]
the
yeah got a little too angry at Aiden
there had a gamer
moment but yeah she she apologized I
mean what what more do you want she it
wasn't like un it wasn't like something
so bad you can never take back but
anyway let's hear aen I could stra up
just say in my chat like I'm going to
Slit your throat and hang you
and like all chill yeah Jesus Christ he
had he had that was a gamer moment gamer
moment gamer moments all around he just
did a Donald Trump I could shoot someone
in the face on Fifth
Avenue these they're not going to give a
I've already put them through so
much they've went to a war and at B
for me every single time I've been
canceled you can't do that and so Aiden
I understand is not very bright so but
he doesn't actually understand what he's
saying fully corroborates what we're
saying he just doesn't know that that's
what he's saying he's misunderstanding
where the Hate's coming the hate is
coming from the inso
right it's not her fans that are angry
I'm vast majority of on the whole I'm
sure maybe some are offended by that and
that's fair he said in chat it's not her
community yeah of course not yeah I
would never I would never assume that
it's the same it's The Usual Suspects
and so it's interesting that he
acknowledges though that I would never
get for
this um but his conclusion is
hilariously wrong and that it's cuz your
community is woke when in fact it's his
people that are the ones came canceling
people and being
um you know absolutely reactive little
freaks also he wouldn't get cancelled
for it because he's famously and
consistently a horrible person that's
you watch for that right and Pokey is
famously and consistently usually a very
pleasant beautiful person so when she
does something that exists in like the
vein of
neutrality then that goes to the news
but when Aiden does that wait that's
such a good point that's must be why
people get upset at me when I mess up
cuz I'm because you're so great yeah
it's just you're so consistently uh
amazing good I am so consistently
beautiful and
amazing
uncontroversial unoffensive go ahead
Aiden no I should say Aiden that's one
side of the spectrum but now let's go to
the other side someone like Mr Beast
who's you know YouTube's Golden Boy what
happens when he sells cookies not
okay but well that's different Mr Beast
wasn't selling like Health cookies and
it wasn't like uh well I thought they
were they were hold on no no they
weren't so they're cheap first of all
they're super cheap I think six six pack
for $30 yeah it's the same they they're
GL free simple ingredients non GMO it's
exact wait wait wait which cookies pull
it up let me see the feasable cookies I
believe this is all in the dock it's oh
it is
yeah uh cuz I thought his cookies were
super in fact I tried to look into it I
couldn't find who manufactured these but
the whole vibe and everything is very
similar I wouldn't be surprised if it's
the same company since this company does
seem to specialize in uh I mean
influencer product first of all Mr Beach
is like Mr ghost kitchen the idea that
he's not white label this is a joke
right these cookies were made by but
yeah he was selling it on his website a
six-pack for $30 so it's a little bit
cheaper right five bucks right and he's
going to sell way more so his profit
margins can be lower yeah Mr Beast can
swing gr on this one it says it's uh the
bag is bigger um weight is 6 o yeah 6 o
compared to was it four Onin other one
it's definitely cheaper than pokey's
bought so but just like the whole
packaging it like cuz the specifically
hold on hold on I don't think they're
marketed as healthy cookies though it
says plant-based and gluten-free but I
don't think they're making any claims I
mean what I'm eating cookies I don't
want to see plant-based and
gluten-free okay I mean I mean I guess
it's not healthy but in the same sense
that uh we were talking about earlier
that I think I mean I I don't think if
it's exactly comparable because then it
just seems like that's not the best way
to defend her I think there's other ways
to Defender that are because Mr Beast
wasn't like oh you're broke if you can't
afford my
cookies to that point that's why right
he never people didn't find like that
the exact same cookie being sold at
Costco there wasn't you know what I mean
like and Mr Beast does get um again I'm
a I'm not
a you're Beast head I got it I'm a beast
head it's still real to be Dam it no but
I'm I am saying
that there's
certain dissimilarities here that that
uh but there's lots of
um Creator products uh like this I
mean goddamn across the board you know I
mean the
the uh go ahead Aiden you're
killing it then you got your best friend
hiss the
snake isan his isan wait why does he
hate Assan so much I thought they were
friends what no I thought hisan was
trying to like no well he for a while
you remember in the early times hisan
was taking the uh concerned older
brother kind of approach with him or
whatever but Aiden that I think that
ended a long time ago well I know hates
Han son so I guess right he's got a fall
in line yeah yeah yeah at one point
Aiden said he should un alive himself if
I'm not that's
cool Jesus on making videos on you
there's no real friends in this industry
you set yourself up for this you have to
pay
now critizing her cuz I don't don't
think that's what hanan's take was I
thought he defended her yeah he did
defend her I think that's what he said
well I think no no he's saying look
making videos on you making videos on
you there's no real friends in this
industry no real friends in this
yeah he totally misinterpreted that God
these people are dumbb gee whiz Aiden
how do you even
breathe God he must sleep with one of
those respirators just cuz he would stop
breathing it's just the brain power is
not
[Laughter]
there golly man you set yourself up for
this you have to pay now you shouldn't
be one to I remember when I got banned
on Twitch she said that I should be
banned for 2 years or some for what
what's that going to teach me you know
it's just like what does that have to do
with her you just sound bitter that she
goofed on you the camp culture people
are now getting canceled
because I laugh at this pokem I don't
think you should be canceled for this
for for the clip but I think you should
be canceled for this because
of what you what you who you are right
what you what your audience is your own
audience is don't think too hard there
buddy don't hurt yourself interestingly
though kind
of in a totally unintentional way is
defending her in a way that he's too
dumb to realize he's doing so kind of a
based I guess uh take it's a little
confused the response but it's like a 80
IQ W take which we
love
w w
uh let's
see yeah so I
mean that's pretty much it then no hold
on I got to see what Charlie had to say
oh Don Charlie needs to talk Charlie
said this this situation is
horrible has he made a video about
Gaza he's like Gaza is horrible no no no
no scratch that these cookies are
horrible it's just kind of I know I'm
not I hate when people do like oh you
can't care about things at once it is a
little funny
though with all the terrible
happening in the
world oh we should be the last to say
that Ethan come
on with the inconsequential that we
talk about all the time I talk about
important things too yeah it's mixed in
but I mean come
on I talk about important things too
I've talked about Gaza I didn't say you
didn't but I'm just saying it's just a
funny to me to Charlie is there like
genocides happening in Congo war in
Ukraine tons of civilians dying
in Gaza Pokey man situation is
horrible maybe I'm being too righteous
about that a little bit yeah maybe I'm
being too I would love to see a Charlie
video on Israel
Palestine I think he's
probably this video like a Palestinian
waiting for his freedom since 1948 no
what's up
guys
heaby today I'm going to be taking the
tunnel into Gaza with the Hamas
operatives whose ass smells like burps
and their burp smells like
sulfur um okay let's see here's the time
stamp Charlie said Pokemon did the worst
thing imaginable when selling a product
okay dive into and get into the weeds of
she by saying that I have full reverence
for Charlie and everything he does
anything that may be perceived as a
slight to him I want to just make clear
that it is not a slight to Charlie uh I
would never say or do anything against
um this great man
mhm and I think did the worst possible
maneuver you could ever do when trying
to sell something to your audience when
people are like oh my God $28 for
cookies
it's four
bags that's seven $7 a bag I know I know
math is
hard when you're an idiot
but like if you're a broke boy just say
so anyway Matt was actually the one that
sent me this clip today and I just
assumed this had to be some kind of bad
joke she tried to tell but watching the
clip it seems like she's legitimately
upset and actually just calling people
that don't want to pay for it or can't
afford it
broke
that's off to a great start
here a elite gamer move that I had to
take a step back to process that she
would just say that publicly I was it's
just not that serious you know that's I
mean call me crazy again there's you can
definitely criticize her for this TR you
know what I mean and but uh I don't
know it seems clear to me that she what
she said is true and that it's just one
annoying dude who was like oh your
cookies cost 28 bucks and she's like no
it's $7 a pack yeah and then you know
she got she had a heater gamer moment
and she said if you're broke just say so
she's being
sassy um that's okay we like
sass we love
sess
right love so dumbfounded upon hearing
that that I actually went back to her
stream VOD where this happened to try
and locate this moment to see what
happened next because this is only 2
seconds I thought there was a chance
that right after it she's like no no
just kidding I'm pulling your leg hardy
har hard just a joke she doesn't do that
she broke she has to say she's joking
for it to be a joke I mean Charlie I
thought you were the Arbiter of comedy
and Truth on the internet he was dumb
fonded oh my goodness I mean what did
you need her to say just kidding and
then it makes it fine you wouldn't give
a if she said just
kidding any
mov
[Music]
what are we watching though I'm more
interested in that right now we need
more people you want to play pay 8 for
Twitter blue for some pixels that's okay
that's
fine you spend your money how you
want I'll spend mine how is this a video
game that she's watching like a dating
Sim I don't know and everyone else will
spend theirs how they want isn't it
weird how it's like it's a sing single
shot of this girl I don't want to run
this art store anymore maybe you're
right maybe it is like a a dating Sim
but with like actual if you're here can
you tell us what game is this or what is
this also the context kind of makes it
even better cuz she's like oh you spend
your money however you want it actually
makes it even better when he shows it
it's just not that serious I don't
know it's not horrible it's not
horrible maybe it's maybe
it's a little awkward
I would never be hyperbolic in
describing anything so I don't know why
Charlie
would Charlie's take is the
worst
thing she is that seems to be where the
topic died at least from what I've
skimmed through here so it doesn't
really seem like she was doing this as
some kind of like s splitting comedy bit
about dude of what is she Jerry
Steinfeld doing a bit about cook po
people and cookies what do you mean s
spit laughing it's not fun what do you
mean by
that what the is he say dude dude
this was clearly not a pre-planned and
rehearsed and Stage tested bit
right I mean that's true it is true he's
accurately assessed that yeah you know
just kidding I actually love my fans she
does giggle about it afterwards but it
feels more like
condescending analysis look at look at
the level of the depth of of
analysis like at JCS video she did laugh
afterwards but it it felt more
condescending than anything thought it
like she thought it was funny to me
no condescending according to Charlie
and Truth is in the be eyes of the
beholder and the beholder is Charlie oh
he's my Northern Star I don't know about
you and then she just says moving on
moving on like it's it's just a really
shitty thing to say then then I feel
like he's not even convinced no he's
just straight on this man is
just trying to make a video that he
knows is going to get a lot of views and
it did it did 5 million after one day
situation is horrible look how he knows
he's reaching it's it's just a really
shitty thing to say right and then she
does what a lot of other people do which
I find really weird which is mentioning
Twitter blue for some reason like
Twitter blue offers this dog
service for $8 you'll spend your money
on some pixels whatever you spend your
money how you want and I'll spend my
money how I want well yeah nobody's
forced do you think maybe you're
overanalyzing to purchase your product
or anything but they were having a legit
discussion on the price just being a
little out of their comfort zone okay
how do you know that what are you
talking about you just made that part up
dude didn't show us what that dude said
to yeah if you wanted me to believe that
you had to show me what that dude said
because you're being super charitable
some random chatter that we all
know and I know you're a streamer no can
be super
unhinged so that's pretty bad faith and
lame Pokey said I really did laugh right
after uh I said everyone should spend
their money how they want 100% intended
to be a joke
no Sor also she said I'll make an eel
flavor cookie for Chad put her on
timeout honesty only Charlie said you're
being
condescending um he also said that the
guy was having a really good faith happy
uh amicable disagreement and that he the
guy who said that was actually like um
was actually a volunteer a firefighter
who yeah they worked at an orphanage
actually do you realize that that dude
was basically a he's an orphan that
works at an orphanage right he was like
the oldest orphan and he adopted all the
other orphans breaking the cycle the
orus orphans that
orus wait Charlie how can you say that
that's so dumb hold on get load
of this but they were having a
legitimate well yeah nobody's forced to
purchase your product or anything but
they were having a legitimate discussion
on the price just being a little out of
their comfort show me that conversation
you I love orus so bad F this man
is straight pandering holy I I've
never seen SE seen him do that so
blatant also critical is known to to
make a video every time a a streamer is
condescending to a shatter every time
you know cuz he's a good cuz he would
never he's never done it before he would
never yeah I don't know he probably
wouldn't I mean he's he's such like a
streamer being condescending to a
singular shatter wow what a big crime
huh he would never do that he's a
good
guy he's cool too he's got tats and
hell yeah dude long hair long hair no I
mean long hair is sick Zach you like
that right you with his hair you
could get a little trim oh you think
it's trimmed up you think it's too long
like if I honestly yeah kind of he needs
a little trim just a little bit just
what would you clean up just to keep it
healthy you know just take like a little
inch maybe inch and a half off
just it grows out better you don't have
split ends and called out look a little
dry that's what I'm saying hold on let's
make a highlight called the Charlie
situation is horrible and it's about
Zach talking about his hair I literally
made a note for that God I me if he
doesn't want to cut it maybe some Olex
or different conditioner
like just saying there it is that's good
advice horrible this is horrible that he
would go out on camera like
this zone for what they'd want to spined
on it like it's a discussion her own
Community was having and then she just
out of nowhere out of left Fields like
if you're broke just say show me that
that's what happened
bro she says that's not what happened
show me the chat blog bro why are you
pandering so hard show us golly G
willikers man what is the G
Willers I don't know but it just it
doesn't need to be like
that Germany Cricket bro that's
a new one I like
that I have no doubt her manager
and her whole team saw this clip and
just together took off their hat stood
up hands on their hips and they're like
you know what it was a good try hey they
staged the walk no that didn't I don't
think that happened Darcy didn't do that
oh my God they all yeah don't you I mean
I see that he's just trying so hard to
make it seem so much worse than it is so
that he can make this
video I love next line he's about to
drop we gave it our best whirl like they
had to have seen this and then
immediately like the office went up in
Flames I don't know what would possess
her to say something she didn't say the
n-word man she didn't like use a racial
slur she just what the
again insensitive not a good thing
to say she did apologize for it she
didn't tell the guy to you
know
so rude and nasty to the audience she is
trying to sell this product to to
directly shame the consumer that you
want to buy into your product is a
Galaxy brain tactic a strategy that I'm
not sure the success rate of like $28 no
matter how you spend this is a lot for
some cookies and I think the way
she keeps trying to break it down it's
four packs I mean again he's not doing a
good job of character of being honest
about that and rationalize it is pretty
disingenuous It's s i mean $ a bag and
that's still expensive but then you also
have to factor in that the bags aren't
even big to begin with it's 4 oz per bag
4 o okay bro you think it's too
expensive I mean what the
oh Pokey said she used to like his
videos but this felt
disingenuous sucks I love Charlie though
I'll never leave him I don't care what
you say about
him I don't think I've seen people uh
point out this is black shirt Charlie
and that white shirt Charlie is uh
better than black shirt Charlie is there
is that like a known thing does he have
better takes in the white shirt this
happened to Jerry uh in the late 80s
they called it the red shirt days Jerry
Garcia and you could see that he was in
danger so um can you pokey do you want
to call in because I do I want to
clarify this point cuz Charlie says that
the chatter you were you were yelling at
was a total gum gentleman who is trying
to have a productive conversation about
the price of your
cookies this is don't even if you
disagree even if what you said we did
this poll in the beginning and like what
almost 40% said that she messed up even
if you're in that side of things can we
acknowledge that this is a whole lot of
hubbub a much a do about nothing in the
words of the great yes William
Shakespeare if you did ever exist but
don't you agree this a whole lot of
stirring over some damn
cookies
especially again with Aiden Ross and XC
and train wreck and all these absolute
scum doing what they do on the
Internet
it's dude how was that me I didn't get
it there's no
way oh it's late I thought I was
going to do a short episode it's goddamn
5 o' the
hell for $7 is still a lot especially
when you compare it to the the product
that they're basing it off of and
supposedly approved upon the totsy
Midnight Cookies those were 10 okay
genius once again it's Costco which has
a membership fee and like she said it
was probably on discount cuz they're
trying to get rid of it thanks $10 a bag
for 14 oz so even though the toi
formulation I don't know what the cost
is on that or $3 more per bag they
offered you 10 oz more of product and
they were sold in Costco a lot of people
really enjoyed them but most people
didn't like the price that was a pain
point of that $10 for a bag of cookies
is a lot oh Charlie spent some time on
the Costco
subreddit I was just thinking is his
Source the same thread because of that
it has to be the top comment was like
$10 for a bag though yeah he's a Costco
head he knows he
knows I mean yeah it listen if you're
something's expensive just don't buy it
you know what I
mean that's it
you know
Charlie
right so $7 for a smaller bag of cookies
significantly smaller is a lot too like
it it doesn't matter how you boil down
this math I feel like if you cut this
whole cookie price analysis just out and
played it it would sound so silly like
Zach can you pull please this cookie
price analysis and just let's just play
it occasionally during wait you want him
talking about the or you want everything
around it no just him talking about the
cookie analysis because like outside of
its element you I feel that you will
realize how silly this this uh video and
this analysis is yeah I can I can do
that thanks being an expensive product
that's the brass tax of it that is the
hard pill to swallow there's really no
way of spinning this where $28 for a
four pack of these cookies isn't
expensive it is and to try and call
people broke for not buying it or not
being able to afford it is really some
out of touch and the Really foul
part about all of this that my little
noodle will never be able to wrap itself
around is a streamer calling Their
audience broke or
poor bu your wealth was built on their
backs them watching you supplied you
with money through the ads that get
played to them them directly donating to
you took their money and gave it to you
if they weren't watching you you would
be getting no sponsors which make up a
lot of streamers hold on there's a oh
whoa Zach what the dude I was
at Costco last week and I saw fighting
some dude over rotisserie yeah gets
heated brother Kos sa Kos sa God I love
that nobody's Crossing you can't go into
Costco Barefoot yes you can if you're
going K sa you can if you're going for
chickens it's War dude
true damn no holds bar so did you get it
or you you bet kimosabi got two
chickens one under each
arm
uh anyway again Charlie keeps saying
that Pokey says she was talking to one
guy not her audience in that makes more
sense to me than her being like she
wasn't like you guys are broke she was
talking to one obnoxious dude I get that
income you need them and you are
dropping trouser and in their
mouth right now by just insulting okay
well hold on I know for a fact that
there's a lot of people in her audience
that would pay for that experience
so true oh I see where you I thought I
thought you knew for a fact that that
didn't happen because you have
mouth with your no it wasn't
that it wasn't about with all the
wasn't about
that them over them having legitimate
criticisms over the price point of the
product it makes no sense your wealth
was accumulated you me the whole video
is like super disingenous and that the
way he's characterizing it as like she's
on her whole audience base and
that they were having this good faith
conversation again none of that
supported but that being said I do I'm
not even blaming Charlie because frankly
listen if that's what he says that's
what it is pokey I don't know what to
say you up it's horrible what you
you did a horrible thing it's
horrible and it is what it is the top
comment is I would not pay $7 for a bag
of cookies even if I was Elon
Musk how would you know what Elon Musk
would do you're not Elon Musk Elon Musk
probably pays way more for cookies he's
known to be good with money too
definitely not wasting 35 billion that
man spent 55 billion on Twitter yeah but
they're just saying if it was was
somebody that they
loved to the extent that they love Elon
Musk her saying all that while
freebooting a show as her job while she
eats overpriced cookies it says I don't
know if she's free booting actually I
don't know what she's doing I don't know
Cam said the game is called love oh is a
game it is a game she playing a video
game so she's not free booting nice 1.2
how did I know I don't know and I I
figured out somehow that was a game yeah
1.2k people just yep like rebooting not
knowing her insulting the audience
mathematical ability WIS at the same
time not understanding proportion
between price and content is funny to me
you are
smart that's all I know Mr
Lemon changing $7 for a little ass bag
of cookies and then calling your fans
broke is absolutely stupid go to the
store and get a 50 pack of Oreos for no
you couldn't 50 pack of Oreos is that
right a 50 pack of Oreos damn for I'm
going Costco bro like right now but it's
not Oreos man it's not Oreos are you
saying they're like the offbrand Oreos a
50 pack of
Oreos that doesn't that's not adding up
skeptical dude I'm skeptical but maybe
let's
See's the big
boy yeah it's pretty nasty here like the
comments are just real nasty for and I
mean it's just not that serious I don't
know
I'm glad Charlie's talking about this
38,000 likes Pokey has been acting like
this for years look up when you try to
get a sponsor to drop a YouTuber who
criticized her a couple years ago who
gives a
probably deserved it I don't know
again another little comment she just
made on
stream what' she say oh that about the
trying to get a sponsor to drop
someone
I've never done that have I ever done
that let's check Charlie's
video didn't Charlie people say I did
that to keemstar I still I still I know
one person who said that you did that to
keemstar keemstar no oh Charlie did that
was he wearing white he did do that I
forgot yeah was it was he in a white
shirt or a black shirt I think he was
wearing a white shirt I kind of up
the whole Theory you're right Charlie
did say that I mean I I I still
listen keemstar got dropped by gfuel and
I got listen they probably dropped him
because of uh I'm assuming all the other
in the video that made it look like
a psychopath right listen I like Charlie
but I'm just going to say he's he sounds
kind of broke I'm just saying he sounds
kind of broke hold on don't first of all
I resent that you're putting words in my
mouth like I don't like Charlie I love
Charlie I did too then you said what
what was your next point I just said
he's sounding kind of broke that's it he
sounds kind of broke sound like a broke
boy I like Charlie I met him and you
know that's all I need to like someone
so you know he's my friend yeah yeah you
guys are best friends
actually so he kind of over did
you over UBS by not promoting the
Creator Clash at all despite being the
announcer this smells
like I watched you open it I was
like what I was putting my trash in
it let's get the out of here man
this has turned into like above average
show and you said you were going to do a
quick one yeah exactly three and a half
hours yeah we end up going for a while
Roman Atwood blackface that'll have to
wait what about the eel pit eel pit
will'll have to
wait so I'll try to do the members
tomorrow but we'll see if well no I
don't think you'll be able
to we're recording that's Friday episode
tomorrow oh okay yeah okay so
there's no so there will be no members
episode tomorrow because we're filming a
full special episode to premiere on
Friday for all your Thanksgiving
enjoyment but thank you to members we
love you guys I love love
everyway she just showed her true colors
it's why happens when your ego continues
to grow over your
morals okay whatever anyway listen like
I says you can I think there's plenty to
criticize here for her I think she made
good apologies for what she did wrong
and I think the that's about it and I
think Charlie's right and he'll always
right and I think he's the best I
love him and his breath probably
doesn't smell like farts his breath
probably smells like pumpkin
pie
fact I'm sure of
it I'm sure of
[Applause]
it have you ever gone after someone
sponsors other than
keemstars
never I think I know like on a person go
ahead I want to know if I did cuz I know
on a personal LEL own you own that's
true depends on how you defined it I
mean you went
[Music]
after sponsors of people like going
after stake for sponsoring streamers but
that's kind of the inverse of no that
doesn't count and I guess James Charles
too we called some people
first that doesn't that doesn't count EI
I mean like going after like hey I don't
like this guy so I'm going to contact
the sponsors to drop
him so okay keemstar I guess has a has
one argument for that but also to the
other extent I'll say this people said
that I could never affect keemstar's
career they said it
where is he now's G where is he now
where is he I miss him yeah well he's
back in a
sense in a sense he's back I can't take
credit for keemstar's demise that was
all
him I he was still around for a year or
two after that whole thing I I I
couldn't take credit for it truly truly
I I believe they're right Keem only
keemstar can undo keemstar right I think
him on Aiden Ross's stream
wasid right that that's true that was
the moment it all went wrong y you're in
trouble that crypto yeah right
forgot about that and he was gloating on
that whole trip to LA and everything he
was saying how much he like owned you
Ethan because I think he got you banned
that week and everything right oh yeah
oh yeah I forgot about that
F's right and then he started yelling at
group of strangers about um your dick
yep and that was a own I owned he's like
just for no reason did you guys know
that Ethan Klein can't get it up
yeah he says so himself you
guys all right anyway listen I don't
know what Pokey said about the sponsored
thing
so whatever AB says it was just one
comment there you go okay right
AB is that
right is that what you said yeah
yeah last
we let
the even was getting up by baby he said
was
even speedit the a grim shaking
fornite a grim shaking fortnite